bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur Public Sénat pour la
séance de l'après-midi consacré
aujourd'hui au bilan annuel
d'applications des lois vous le savez
peut-être et bien a été créé en 2011 au
Sénat une commission d'applications des
lois et les présidée par le sénateur
socialiste David Assouline et elle
publie donc aujourd'hui ses statistiques
autour de l'application des lois
adoptées pendant la session
parlementaire 2012-2013 alors le taux
global d'applications des lois de cette
sessions parlementaires et bien tourne
autour de 65% ce qui est pas mal
notamment par rapport à certaines
législatures précédentes mais les marges
de progression restent encore importante
surtout quand on regarde de près ces
statistiques on s'aperçoit que
finalement les lois qui sont adoptées en
procédure accélérée donc en urgence ne
sont finalement pas mieux appliquer par
le gouvernement que les lois adoptées
dans une procédure normale voilà pour
voir tout le détail un peu des
statistiques autour de l'application des
lois et bien direction tout de suite
l'hémicycle du Sénat une séance qui
commence par le discours du président de
la commission d'application des lois
David Assouline suivi des interventions
des orateurs des différentes commissions
du Sénat très bonne séance à tous sur
notre antenne l'ordre du jour appelle le
débat sur le bilan annuel de
l'application des lois organisée à la
demande de la commission sénatoriale
pour les contrôles de l'application des
lois la parole est à Monsieur David
Assouline président de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois vous avez la
parole monsieur le président
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
Présidents
des commissions permanentes chers
collègues
c'est un débat qui intervient un moment
où beaucoup ont les yeux tournés vers
une échéance dans de dans deux heures
importantes pour le pays pour ceux qui
aiment le sport je sais que monsieur
clarucci est indifférent à tout cela
mais nous sommes ici au travail et nous
sur un sujet tout à fait important nous
sommes réunis donc pour la discussion du
bilan annuel de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
d'année en année ce débat est devenu
indépend fort de l'activité de contrôle
du Sénat je remercie le gouvernement
d'avoir accepté de l'inscrire à l'ordre
du jour dans une séance dans cette
séance ordinaire ce qui témoigne de
l'intérêt qu'il y porte à l'approche du
prochain renouvellement Triana du Sénat
il me donne aussi l'occasion de dresser
un rapide bilan des trois premières
années d'activité de cette commission je
serai très bref vous en trouverez les
données détaillées dans mon rapport
écrit et vous constaterez que depuis sa
mise en place effective en janvier 2012
cette nouvelle Commission a beaucoup
travaillé les sept véritablement
installée dans les institutions du Sénat
partant de rien elle a inventé ces
méthodes de travail en bonne harmonie
avec les commissions permanentes avec la
Conférence des Présidents et avec le
gouvernement je tiens à souligner le
soutien que nous avons trouvé auprès de
chacun de nos interlocuteurs naturels et
président de commission permanente même
si c'est une épave pour tous de
engager ce type de collaboration le
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement et que ce soit le prédécesseur
de Monsieur Leguen et Monsieur Le Guen
mais aussi monsieur Ollier avant et
le secrétaire général du gouvernement en
particulier que je veux saluer qui est
son bras armé du gouvernement pour
toutes ces questions d'application des
lois finalement la Commission s'est
installée sans heure dans un paysage
institutionnel du Sénat favorisant de
nouvelles approches et de nouveaux
réflexes et que j'ai coutume d'appeler
la nouvelle culture du contrôle et de
l'évaluation comme je l'ai souvent dit à
cette tribune le Parlement aujourd'hui
ne peut plus se contenter de voter les
lois nous devons aussi contrôler la
manière dont ces lois s'appliquent et
vérifier si elles répondent vraiment non
seulement aux attentes de nos
concitoyens mais à ce qu'a voulu le
législateur quand il a élaboré la loi
c'est un enjeu de démocratie une
question de crédibilité de l'action
publique et de confiance dans
l'institution parlementaire en outre je
vois une continuité logique évidente
entre la fonction de contrôle et la
fonction législative en faisant le bilan
des législations en vigueur nous pouvons
identifier leur faiblesse ou leur
lacunes et envisagée des améliorations
nécessaires ou les rectifications
nécessaires quand l'application s'est
avéré
contraire ou en tous les cas avec des
effets que n'avaient pas envisagé le
législateur et ça arrive quelquefois de
ce fait le contrôle des bouches de
lui-même sur une amélioration de notre
environnement normatif que nous essayons
de rendre plus simple plus lisible et
plus proche des besoins réels en tous
les cas c'est une volonté affirmée par
l'ensemble des parlementaires
aujourd'hui certes nos moyens de
contrôle sont limités je leur ai affirme
par rapport à d'autres assemblées bien
sûr comme le Sénat américain mais
nous savons que notre système
institutionnel
n'est pas le même en France c'est le
gouvernement qui dispose des moyens
matériels et politiques du contrôle
c'est un des paradoxes institutionnels
du système de la 5ème République les
assemblées sont obligés de demander au
gouvernement les moyens les informations
qui leur sont nécessaires pour exercer
leur contrôle sur le gouvernement
lui-même par ailleurs la recherche de la
qualité de la législation ne doit pas
faire tomber dans le travers inverse qui
consisterait à évaluer cette qualité
uniquement sur des critères de
performance ou de rentabilité comme en
tant que c'est rentré dans le discours y
compris
quand il s'agit de fabriquer la loi
le critère qui définit une bonne loi
dépend avant tout de la perception
politique de chacun il est de nature de
la loi et de l'action du Parlement
d'exprimer des projets politiques et des
options de société qui seront déclinées
en texte juridique au service d'une
politique publique au Parlement de
trouver la meilleure voie entre une
démarche trop strictement politique dont
la qualité juridique pourrait empathie
et une approche trop technique qui
limiterait l'expression des choix
politiques pour en venir au bilan annuel
de l'application des lois dont vous
trouverez les statistiques détaillées
dans mon rapport écrit je retiendrai
quatre grandes tendances la première une
production législative soutenue sur la
période de référence
50 lois ont été promulgués hors
convention internationale soit un haut
niveau d'activité législatives durant
cette première année pleine du
quinquennat sur ces 50 lois 19 lois sont
issus de propositions de sénateurs ou de
députés soient presque 40% de
législation d'initiatives parlementaire
le Sénat avec 11 propositions de loi a
été l'an dernier à l'origine de plus
d'une loi sur 5
la montée en puissance de l'initiative
parlementaire est un des effets positifs
de la révision constitutionnelle du
juillet 2008 ils sont trop rares pour
qu'on ne les signalent pas
deuxième grande tendance les
pourcentages de mise en application des
lois se sont maintenus cette année au
niveau élevé de l'exercice précédent
pour faire simple retenons cet
indicateur le taux global de mise en
application des mesures législatives
adoptées en 2012-2013 a atteint 64%,
soit 2 à 3 fois plus que ce constater
jusqu'en 2010 donc cette tendance à la
hausse se maintient depuis 2010 c'est la
dernière année du précédent quinquennat
avec l'impulsion que j'ai souvent salué
de Monsieur Ollier l'application des
lois a été une priorité forte des deux
derniers gouvernements nous devons leur
en donner acte dès son entrée en
fonction le gouvernement de Jean-Marc
Rault avait confirmé l'objectif posé en
2008 rarement respecté jusque là de
faire paraître des traits d'application
des lois nouvelles dans un délai maximum
de six mois
quand au gouvernement de Manuel Valls
vous nous avez indiqué en commission
monsieur le ministre que le cap serait
maintenu si on raisonne en nombre de
lois troisième grande tendance
on constate que 90% des lois de la
session 2012-2013 sont en application
partielle ou totale
14e grandes tendances
enfin sur l'ensemble des textes de la
14e législature c'est-à-dire l'actuel
législature avec cette majorité la pente
et la même déjà 88% de loi en
application partielle ou totale même
s'il est bien sur trop tôt pour en tirer
des enseignements définitifs au final
on n'est pas encore au 100% que le
Parlement serait en droit d'attendre
c'est si on fait la loi c'est pour 100%
s'applique mais ces résultats traduisent
une réelle prise de conscience
aujourd'hui plus personne n'accepterait
le taux calamiteux des années
précédentes à 2010 je suis convaincu que
la création de notre commission est
favoriser cette évolution et je suis
certain qu'elle y est pour quelque chose
car elle a porté la question de
l'application des lois dans le débat
politique ce qui a mis le gouvernement
sous pression un bilan positif donc mais
où on relève pourtant quatre éléments
moins favorables que je veux décliner 1
tout d'abord la mise en application des
textes issus de l'initiative
parlementaire et moins bonne que celle
des textes d'origine gouvernementale
notamment pour ceux qui concerne les
amendements mais pas seulement
circonstances aggravantes le
gouvernement montre plus d'empressement
pour les textes de l'Assemblée nationale
que pour ceux du Sénat
c'est à dire qu'en gros déjà ce qui
vient d'initiative parlementaire se
traduisent moins vite par des décrets
mais à l'intérieur de cette initiative
parlementaire déjà maltraités le Sénat
est particulièrement moins bien traité
que l'assemblée cette année les taux
atteignent respectivement 67% pour les
amendements du Gouvernement 48% pour
ceux de l'assemblée et 24% pour ceux du
Sénat et le Sénat est en droit de
exprimer un certain désappointement mais
aussi une colère pour rectifier cela
de
bémol l'application des lois votées
selon la procédure accélérée n'a pas été
plus rapide que c'est que celle des
autres lois alors à quoi bon imposer au
Parlement des cadences rapides c'est
l'urgence invoquait en amont but en aval
sur les des délais incompressibles donc
important je le souligner
je ne remets pas en cause parfois la
nécessité de l'urgence c'est parce qu'il
y a urgence pour la société si derrière
les décrets mettent plus de temps
et bien c'est annulé et donc c'est
seulement le travail parlementaire qui
aura été par cette urgence mais
non pas la nécessité que ça rentre vite
dans la vie de nos concitoyens on peut
comprendre qu'un gouvernement quel qu'il
soit n'est pas dans ses priorités la
mise en application des lois issues
d'une autre majorité parlementaire
c'est la troisième bémol mais le taux de
mise en application du stock ancien
c'est à dire des lois antérieures à 2007
végètent sans aucun progrès notable mais
c'est pas seulement cette nouvelle
majorité le choc ancien c'est avant 2007
voilà on pourrait dire avant
telle ou telle date c'est-à-dire de
on va en arrière d'une législature non
seulement de 2007 à 2012 avec la même
majorité politique on sait pas empressé
de faire appliquer les lois mais bon on
peut pas non plus complètement critiquer
l'actuel majorité qui n'a pas à montrer
un empressement encore plus ailé que le
précédent pour faire appliquer les lois
de l'autre majorité
sur le plan des principes je trouve
choquant que les lois puissent rester
inappliquées pendant des années et
finissent par devenir obsolète sans que
juridiquement on est abrogé ou donner
une explication à tous les cas formels à
cette non-application pour y trouver
remède
enfin dernier bémol on constate qu'aucun
progrès significatif dans la remise des
rapports d'information cette année
encore beaucoup de rapport attendus
n'ont pas été présentés ceux qui l'ont
été n'apportaient pas toujours des
informations très exploitables ce
constat vaut aussi bien pour les
rapports à présenter en vertu d'une
disposition législative ponctuelle que
pour les rapports dit de l'article 67
dans lesquels le gouvernement doit faire
le point sur la mise en application de
toute nouvelle loi six mois après sa
promulgation je parle bien donc de deux
types de rapports ce classiquement qu'au
moment d'une discussion de loi par
amendement le Sénat demande un rapport
très souvent pour appeler un débat
derrière les rapports viennent rarement
donc ça oblige deux choses au
parlementaire de ne pas exagérer cette
demande et de ne pas détourner la
procédure pour pouvoir avoir un débat de
demander un rapport bien ça c'est nous
soyons plus sérieux mais si c'est
demandé de toute façon voter par les
assemblées il faut des rapports sérieux
remis par le gouvernement ou en tous les
cas tels que législateur l'a voulu puis
sur les articles 67 qui sont les
rapports sur l'application ils sont trop
inégaux et très peu exploités par les
commissions et bien entendu tant qu'ils
sont peu exploités par les commissions
l'administration le gouvernement le LGG
n'est pas empressé d'en faire des
meilleurs bien donc si tout le monde est
lisait il serait bon et en tous les cas
c'est la loi il faut ces rapports il
faut les faire monsieur le ministre
j'avais déjà attiré l'attention de votre
prédécesseur sur cette question l'an
dernier vous avez reconnu lors de votre
audition que cela reste un point faible
sur le quel nous devons réfléchir
de concert car les parlementaires ont
une part de responsabilité dans cette
situation nous demandons trop de rapport
souvent comme l'autre consolation en
échange et le retrait d'un amendement ma
conviction et que nous devrions demander
moins de rapport et mieux tirer parti de
ceux qui nous sont remis
qui tend maintenant le terrain des
statistiques j'en viens à quelques
considérations plus générales sur
l'amélioration de l'environnement
normatif dont j'ai rappelé l'importance
au début de mon propos chaque pas dans
cette direction renforcera la confiance
dans l'institution parlementaire et en
particulier dans le Sénat moins tenu par
la logique majoritaire que l'Assemblée
nationale à cet effet nous devons
renforcer l'efficacité des procédures
existantes pour que nos pratiques et le
suivi de nos actions de contrôle des
mouches sur des améliorations de la
législation en vigueur j'ai formulé dans
mon rapport écrit plusieurs propositions
concrètes notamment pour tirer meilleure
partie des questions parlementaires et
de leur suivi au service de
l'application des lois
vous nous avez indiqué Monsieur le
Ministre que vous étiez prêt à vous
joindre à cette réflexion en relayant
les alertes que ma commission pourrait
désormais
tirée si une question écrite concernant
l'application de la loi n'a pas obtenu
de répondre dans des délai requis ou
même accélérer ces délais parfois
c'est un des chantiers concrets sur
lequel nous pourrons travailler dès la
prochaine rentrée parlementaire je
préconise également de mieux réguler la
pratique du renvoi en décréant Conseil
d'État ce qui est une des causes de
l'engorgement du processus réglementaire
pas d'abus dans la plupart des cas on
obtiendrait les mêmes garanties par un
envoi en décret simple voire pas du tout
de renvoi
bon je vais
conclure dans cet ensemble je voudrais
souligner certaines mesures prises cette
année pour faciliter le dialogue
normatif entre l'État les collectivités
territoriales elles font l'écho exprimés
par les États généraux de la démocratie
territoriale initié par notre président
Jean-Pierre Bel nous le savons tous les
collectivités territoriales rencontrent
de grandes difficultés dans la mise en
œuvre des normes surtout les petites et
moyennes communes
là il faut une avancée significative
avec ce choc de simplification qui
devrait remplacer le choc de
complications que nous vivons en
permanence il faut donc saluer la
création à l'initiative du Sénat d'un
conseil national en charge de
l'évaluation des normes applicable aux
collectivités territoriales je veux
aussi
issu de la proposition de Messieurs
monsieur monsieur
saluer la nomination d'un ministre
monsieur Thierry Manon pour en charge de
cette simplification globalement de
notre environnement normatif et je salue
aussi l'installation d'un médiateur
spécialisé pour favoriser le dialogue
normatif entre l'administration et les
collectivités fonctions qui viennent
d'être confiée à notre ancien collègue
Alain Lambert et bien voilà pour
conclure et pour finir vous dire que
nous avons commencé un travail nouveau
nous l'avons amplifié au Sénat avec
cette commission les rapports montrent
que il y a des résultats mais il faut
pas baisser la garde parce que je pense
que
ce qu'il y a à
parfaire dans le travail législatif
français c'est avant tout d'assumer
notre fonction
écrite dans la constitution de contrôle
de l'exécutif
compensant notre manque de moyens pour
le faire vraiment par une forte volonté
politique et une attention particulière
de l'ensemble de nos bancs merci
je vous remercie
monsieur le Président de la commission
sénatoriale pour les contrôles de
l'application des lois la parole est à
Claudine au nom de la commission les
affaires économiques
Claudie land du groupe socialiste
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je dois d'abord
excuser le président daniel Raoul qui
n'a pas pu se libérer mais c'est avec
beaucoup d'honneur que je vais vous
transmettre ces conclusions
ce rapport établit cette année par la
commission que président daniel Raoul
après la scission comme vous le savez en
deux commissions prend en compte 26 lois
l'étude de certains textes trop anciens
n'étant plus jugé pertinente le bilan
dressé en 2014 mesure l'application des
lois promulguées depuis 2003 jusqu'au 30
septembre 2013
sur les 26 lois dont l'application est
suivie cette année par la commission des
affaires économiques 9 sont totalement
applicables on remarque même que trois
des quatre lois promulguées entre le
premier octobre 2012 et le 30 septembre
2013 étudier de ce fait pour la première
fois cette année dans le bilan de la
commission des affaires économiques sont
d'ores et déjà totalement applicable
s'agit de la loi du 20 novembre 2012
relative à la régulation économique
outre-mer et portant diverses
expressions relatives aux outre-mer de
la loi du 18 janvier 2013 relative à la
mobilisation du foncier public en faveur
du logement et au renforcement de la
production de logements social et la loi
du 1er juillet 2013 habilitant le
gouvernement a adopté des mesures de
nature législatives pour accélérer les
projets de construction et ceci est
totalement satisfaisant
s'agissant de la loi numéro 2013 509
habilitant le gouvernement à légiféré
par ordonnance pour accélérer le projet
de construction celle-ci est considérée
formellement d'application directe mais
il est intéressant de relever que non
seulement les certes ordonnances prévues
ont été adoptés dans les délais mais
aussi que 6 d'entre elles ont d'ores et
déjà été ratifiées par l'article 174 de
la loi du 24 mars 2014 des lois allure
nous pouvons nous le féliciter à ce
sujet d'ailleurs que Cécile Duflot alors
ministre du Logement est pris la peine
de venir spécifiquement par deux fois
présenter ces textes devant notre
commission
néanmoins en sortant des bornes
d'examens de ce bilan d'application des
lois le président souhaite relever la
longueur des délais pris pour l'adoption
d'un décret relatif au pouvoir de
sanction de la recette
dans un arrêt du 5 juillet 2013 le
Conseil constitutionnel a jugé contraire
à la Constitution les dispositions de
l'article l3611 relative au pouvoir de
fonction de sanction pardon de l'ARCEP
considérant que la séparation des
pouvoirs d'instruction et de sanctions
n'étaient pas respectées
ceci a eu pour conséquence de priver
l'autorité de ce pouvoir de sanction qui
constitue l'un des moyens fondamentaux
de son action ceci est particulièrement
problématique dans un secteur à fort
taux de contentieux
enfin afin de combler cette carence le
gouvernement introduit à l'article 1
l'article premier pardon de la loi du 2
janvier 2014 habilitant le gouvernement
à simplifié et sécurisé la vie des
entreprises une disposition votée par le
Parlement l'autorisant à prendre par
ordonnance des mesures de nature
législatives propre à sécuriser au sein
du code des postes et des communications
électroniques le pouvoir de sanction de
la recette à l'encontre des opérateurs
concernés cette ordonnance du 12 mars
2014 relative à l'économie numérique
instaure dans les secteurs de la Poste
des communications électroniques une
nouvelle procédure de sanction selon le
modèle de la Commission Nationale
Informatique et Liberté dont la
Constitution la constitutionnalité a été
validée par le Conseil d'État mais le
décret devant venir préciser ces
modalités les modalités de ces
dispositions n'a à ce jour toujours pas
été publiée ce qui est fort regrettable
compte tenu de l'urgence pour quelles
raisons monsieur le ministre décret n'a
pas été pris et à quel horizon sera-t-il
pris
en outre l'étude des 17 lois
partiellement applicables
dont l'application est suivie cette
année par la commission des affaires
économiques aboutit à un bilan mitigé
exception faite de deux lois la loi du
25 mars 2009 de mobilisation pour le
logement et la lutte contre l'exclusion
et la loi du 27 juillet 2010 de
modernisation de l'agriculture de la
pêche pour lesquelles ont été pris
respectivement un décret en Conseil
d'État et de décrets simples à
l'exception de ça aucune mesure
réglementaire n'a été prise depuis le
bilan établi en 2013 ainsi en est-il par
exemple de la loi du 20 mai 2005
relative à la régularisation des
activités postales applicables à 80% de
même la loi du 25 juillet 2008 relative
aux organismes génétiquement modifiés
est applicable à 50% et la loi est et
voilà c'est tout par ailleurs
il est regrettable de constater que
parmi le stock des lois étudiées par la
commission des affaires économiques
l'unique loi d'initiative sénatoriale la
loi du 8 décembre 2011 relative au
certificat d'obtention végétal soit
celle qui affiche un taux d'applications
le plus faible
12%. les décrets encore attendus par ce
texte issu d'une proposition de loi
présentée par Christian Deck et
plusieurs collègues annoncés pour la fin
du premier semestre 2013 n'avait
toujours pas été publié au 31 mars 2014
sur les 26 lois dans l'application est
suivi cette année par la commission
d'affaires coniques 14 ont été votés par
procédure accélérée on peut relever que
les quatre lois étudiées pour la
première fois cette année dans le bilan
de la Commission ont été votés selon
procédure cette procédure
nous pouvons nous ne pouvons cependant
que nous étonner de constater que lui
loi dont l'application est encore
étudiée par la commission cette année
promulgué entre 2004 et 2011 après
engagement de la procédure accélérée ou
après déclaration d'urgence ne sont
encore que partiellement applicables
sur les 26 lois dans l'application SUV
cette année par la Commission des
Affaires comiques une seule a fait
l'objet d'une remise d'un rapport en
vertu de l'article 67 de la loi du 9
décembre 2004 sur la simplification du
droit depuis le bilan établi en 2013 un
seul rapport
qu'il s'agissait du rapport sur la mise
en application de la loi numéro 2012
1270 du 20 novembre 2012
qui avait été qui a été présenté au
Parlement le 14 mars 2004 avec mais un
certain retard
cette absence de rapport est regrettable
pour la bonne information des
parlementaires sur les textes suivis
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous en
dire plus sur cet état de fait
comme le comme l'année dernière le
président Raoult déplore la défaillance
dont fait preuve l'administration en ce
qui concerne la remise des rapports au
Parlement les chiffres sont éloquents
s'être apports prévus par certaines
dispositions de loi dont la commission
des affaires économiques assure le suivi
ont été rendus au cours de la période
nouvellement étudiée cette année à
savoir le premier avril 2013 au 31 mars
2014 7 rapports ont été rendus alors que
35 sont encore attendus je ne vais rien
dire de plus qu'a dit le président
Assouline si ce n'est que le président
daniel Raoul se pose même la question de
opposer quelquefois un article 40 à la
demande de rapport qui s'ils sont pas
souvent utilisés sont toujours coûteux
pour finir
je voudrais me féliciter de la
coopération de mise en place entre la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de la réplique saison des lois et les
commissions permanentes après le rapport
d'information sur le tourisme de nos
collègues lucarbonate vinaigre et
Jean-Jacques Lasserre publiés en octobre
dernier qui dressait un bilan en
demi-teinte de la loi du 22 juillet 2009
un rapport contre l'application de la
loi du 23 juillet de 19 2010 pardon
relative au réseau consulaire au
commerce à l'artisanat et au service est
en cours de rédaction par nos collègues
Claude berrydebat en tant que sénateur
de la commission des affaires
économiques et Jean-Claude Benoît en
tant que membre de la commission
sénatoriale pour tôle de l'application
des lois ce rapport sera examiné par nos
deux commissions en réunion conjointe le
9 juillet prochain au delà d'un bilan
purement quantitatif ces rapports
permettent d'apprécier l'effectivité de
l'application des lois au regard des
objectifs fixés par le législateur
n'oublions pas mes chers collègues que
c'est ainsi que 100 ans la fonction de
contrôle du Parlement reconnue par la
réforme constitutionnelle de
2008 et je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est à Daniel Renner
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées au nom de la Commission
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues notre
collègue président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense
Jean-Louis carrer est retenu et donc je
prends sa place avec beaucoup de plaisir
dans ce débat sur l'application des lois
tout d'abord notre commission salut
l’excellent travail de cette commission
monsieur le Président
ça témoigne naturellement de la grande
importance que le Sénat attache au suivi
de l'application des lois qu'il adopte
avant de vous présenter le bilan de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense des forces armées pour l'année
parlementaire 2012-2013 je ne résiste
pas au plaisir de vous dire à quelle
profonde satisfaction notre Commission a
reçu la semaine dernière le rapport sur
l'entrée en programmation militaire 2014
alors même que la loi lui faisait
obligation de faire ce rapport un an
après et donc nous nous retrouvons
naturellement en juin 2015 pour faire ce
rapport donc avoir un rapport qu'on
avait pas vraiment demandé ça peut
arriver la preuve
c'est bien voyons maintenant le vif du
sujet comme chaque année
l'essentiel de l'activité législatives
de notre commission consiste à examiner
des projets de loi autorisant des
ratifications ou d'approuver des traités
ou encore internationaux dans cette
année parlementaire
2012-2013 le Sénat a adopté en sciences
publiques 55 accords internationaux qui
relevaient donc de notre commission
certains de ces accords n'ont pas encore
été examinés par l'Assemblée nationale
et donc les lois n'ont pas été
promulguées mais finalement ça n'a pas
grande importance puisque je rappelle
ici que ces conventions et ces accords
ne sont pas pris en compte dans le
contrôle de la mise en application des
lois
à côté des conventions accordées la
commission examinée en tant que
Commission saisie au fond un seul projet
de loi qui intéresse les questions de
défense ou à faire étrangères entre 1er
octobre 2012 et 30 septembre 2013 il
s'agissait d'un projet de loi qui
portait application du protocole
additionnel de l'accord entre la France
la Communauté européenne de l'énergie
atomique et l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie atomique relatif à
l'application des garanties en France
qui avait été signé à Vienne en 98 on
avait mis 15 ans pour la prouver
toutefois ce texte ne compte pas au nom
des lois mais au nombre des lois
promulguées pendant la période observée
puisque l'Assemblée nationale ne l'a pas
encore examiné à ce jour
pour mémoire ce texte avait été examiné
en juin 2013 par la commission adoptée
en juillet 2013 et il a été transmis le
23 juillet 2013 à la santé et donc au 31
mars 2014 la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
continuent-ils l'application de 11 lois
adoptées au cours de la saison c'est la
session 2012-2013 et il n'appliquable à
des degrés divers
faut noter que dans le stock des lois
suivies par la Commission et qui ne sont
pas totalement applicables à 100% aucun
texte d'application n'a été pris aucune
loi des devenus totalement applicable
pendant cette session et que parmi les
mesures d'applications prises pendant
cette période octobre 12 31 mars 2014 on
compte un degré un décret simple qui
modifie un décret déjà pris relatif à
l'attribution d'une indemnité
d'accompagnement de reconversion et le
rapport annuel du Parlement sur
l'exécution de la loi de programmation
militaire pour les années 2009 2014
ainsi que deux autres rapports
d'évaluation dont je vous redirai
quelques mots dans un instant donc je me
contenterai de quelques observations
puisque aucune loi relevant du secteur
de notre commission n'a été prélevé
promulgué au cours de cette session
s'agissant du stock antérieur des 11
lois en attente il faut noter que la
majorité de ces lois sont partiellement
applicables et 5 d'entre elles avec des
taux relativement élevés en revanche le
commission continue de regretter que la
loi du 28 juillet 2011 tendance à
faciliter l'utilisation des réserves
militaires et civiles en cas de crise
majeure demeure totalement inapplicable
donc trois ans après puisque aucune des
quatre mesures d'applications prévues
n'a été prise à ce jour ça mérite une
explication d'autant que cette loi fera
l'objet d'un rapport d'information de la
part de la Commission pour le contrôle
et l'application des lois l'année
prochaine donc nous l'attendons avec
beaucoup d'intérêt
puisque nous évoquons ces travaux
naturellement excellents de cette
commission je tiens à mentionner son
rapport qui est la publié en septembre
2013 sur l'indemnisation des victimes
des essais nucléaires français une loi
qui n'a pas atteint ses objectifs nous
cette loi nous concernait naturellement
et ce document dressé un constat pour le
moins réservé selon moi les termes du
communiqué de presse et notre commission
partage d'autant plus volontiers les
conclusions de ce rapport que le
ministre de la Défense nous le notons a
été questionné à 14 reprises sur ce
sujet pendant la période de référence
comme ce fut le cas d'ailleurs au cours
de la session précédente
s'agissant des rapports reçus entre
octobre 2012 et mars 2014 outre le
rapporte de l'exécution de la loi de
programmation militaire le Parlement a
reçu deux rapports d'évaluation sur la
loi de 27 juillet 2010 relative à
l'action extérieure de l'État
conformément un échéancier qui avait été
mis en place pour suivre les résultats
de l'expérimentation du rattachement à
l'Institut français du réseau culturel
de la France à l'étranger
voilà tout n'est pas parfait cependant
puisque au 31 mars 2014 nous attendons
encore 4 rapports pour des lois adoptées
il y a fort longtemps forte ancienne
datant de 94 97 98 et 2000 peut-être
pourrions-nous avoir quelques
explications sur le fait que ces
rapports ne soient pas publiés en
conclusion je rappelle que la Commission
des Affaires étrangères a parfaitement
conscience de l'importance du travail
d'évaluation qui est fait et qu'elle
entend continuer à y prendre sa part
pour que les lois adoptées deviennent
applicables si possible dans des délais
raisonnables je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
la parole est à Catherine Génisson
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
permettez-moi tout d'abord de
transmettre les regrets d'Annie David
président de la commission des affaires
sociales qui m'a demandé en qualité de
vice-présidente d'exposer les
principales observations de notre
commission à l'occasion de sublimant
annuelle la première visa souligner
cette année encore tout l'intérêt de se
débat qui sera s'appuie sur le rapport
extrêmement documenté élaboré par la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois celle-ci a en
effet réalisé une synthèse des constats
dressés par chaque commission permanente
en l'enrichissant des enseignants des
enseignements tirés de ses propres
travaux merci monsieur le Président nous
apprécions également l'intérêt que le
gouvernement porte à la question de
l'application des lois sa participation
est celle de ses services aux réunions
organisées par le président David
Assouline
j'en viens plus précisément aux
observations de notre commission durant
l'année parlementaire 2012-2013 le
Parlement a adopté 14 lois examinaient
au fond par la commission des affaires
sociales un nombre particulièrement
élevé qui n'avait pas été atteint depuis
la session 2007 2008 sur ces 14 lois les
cinq résultats d'initiative
gouvernementale et neuf d'une initiative
parlementaire
c'est loin des implications extrêmement
variables en termes de mesure
d'application 6 d'entre elles pouvaient
s'appliquer directement sans texte
réglementaire pour lui pour les huit
autres un total de 132 mesures
d'applications étaient attendues dont 77
pour la seule loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
globalement un peu plus de 100 usure
avec été prise au 31 mars 2014 soit un
tout proche de 80% nettement supérieur à
ceux qui avaient été jusqu'à présent
constaté les années précédentes près de
40% des mesures attendues avaient été
prises dans les six mois de la
promulgation c'est-à-dire dans les
délais fixés par la circulaire
gouvernementale de 2008 est près des
trois quarts l'avait été dans un délai
d'un an ce résultat est plutôt
satisfaisant au regard des expériences
passées la Commission se félicite de
constater que la tendance à
l'amélioration lente mais continue de
l'édiction des mesures réglementaires
d'application c'est un niveau c'est à
nouveau confirmé au cours de l'indé
parlementaire 2012-2013 mais cette note
générale positive ne doit cependant pas
masquer une réalité très contrastée
le gouvernement s'efforce de rapidement
mettre en oeuvre les dispositifs qui est
jugent prioritaires cela a été le cas
pour les lois intervenus dans le domaine
du travail et de l'emploi et on ne sont
non plus que son féliciter les lois sur
les emplois d'avenir et sur le contrat
de génération ont reçu 100% de leur
mesure d'application pour les emplois
d'avenir le premier décret est intervenu
6 jours après la promulgation pour le
contrat de génération les 10 mesures
attendues étaient prises 2 semaines
après la promulgation
s'agissant de la loi relative à la
sécurisation de l'emploi promulguée en
juin 2013 plus de 70% des mesures
d'applications avaient été prises au 31
mars dernier
la principale disposition en attente et
cependant très importantes puisqu'elle
concerne l'article premier relatif à la
couverture complémentaire santé nous
savons que la préparation du décret
fixant le niveau minimal de garantie des
contrats collectifs concernés est
impacté par les mesures de la loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale pour 2014
relative au contrat solidaire et
responsable les projets de texte sont
actuellement dans leur phase ultime de
finalisation
même si la généralisation des contrats
collectifs vont entreprises des
applicable qu'au 1er janvier 2016 la
Commission insiste sur le fait que la
parution des textes d'application est
indispensable au lancement des
négociations de branches qui ont pris du
retard
s'agissant de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale le gouvernement a
fait en sorte de promulguer rapidement
les textes d'application près de 90%
d'entre eux étant paru au 31 mars
dernier à l'inverse 4 lois tout issu
d'une initiative parlementaire non fait
l'objet d'aucune mesure d'application
sur les 15 décrets ou arrêter qu'elle
prévoyait
il en est ainsi de la loi du 30 mai 2013
portant réforme de la biologie médicale
certes un des principaux objets de la
loi à savoir ratifier l'ordonnance de
2010 a été atteint mais la loi avait
également introduit des dispositions
nouvelles qui nécessitaient d'y
décrégoire aucun n'a été pris cette loi
est issue d'une procédure parlementaire
particulièrement longue qui a donné lieu
à des concertation nombreuses avec les
acteurs
avec les acteurs concernés cela leur a
dû auraient dû permettre une parution
rapide des textes réglementaires
notamment des arrêtés
la loi du 27 septembre 2013 sur les
soins psychiatriques nécessité trois
mesures d'applications qui n'ont pas été
prises les mesures réglementaires
attendues portent sur des points
importants pour la prise en charge des
malades et la procédure d'expertise
psychiatrique les trois décrets en
Conseil d'État prévu par la loi n'ont
pas encore été soumis aux sections
compétentes il est souhaitable qu'il
soit pris dans les meilleurs délais et
vous y serez particulièrement sensible
monsieur le ministre
la loi du 3 juin 2013 vivant visant à
garantir la qualité de l'offre
alimentaire outre-mer voit également son
article premier rendu inopérant faute de
mesure d'applications et cela est grave
en matière de santé publique
enfin s'agissant de la loi du 24
décembre 2012 suspendant la fabrication
et la mise sur le marché des
conditionnements alimentaires contenant
du bisphénol A ce sont plutôt des enjeux
de conformité aux droits communautaire
qui retarde la parution d'un décret
d'application et engendre des
incertitudes sur l'effectivité de la loi
elle-même en effet une phase
pré-contensieuse a été ouverte contre la
France la Commission européenne a
tendance toutefois pour se prononcer une
nouvelle évaluation des risques associés
au bisphénol A utilisé dans les
conditionnements alimentaires par
l'Autorité européenne de sécurité des
aliments et on peut se féliciter là de
l'intransigence de la France sur ces
questions là
au cours de la période étudiée près
d'une vingtaine de mesures
réglementaires sont intervenus en
application de loi votée sous la
précédente précédente législatures la
Commission se félicite particulièrement
bien qu'elle ait été tardive plus d'un
an et demi après la propulsation de la
loi de l'apparition du décret organise
en la transmission des informations
entre département afin d'assurer le
suivi des enfants en danger en cas de
déménagement des familles à l'inverse la
loi du 5 mars 2012 relative recherche
appliquant la personne humaine est
encore privée d'une partie notable de
ses effets les mesures réglementaires
mettant en place la structure nationale
chargée de la répartition aléatoire des
protocoles de recherche entre les
comités de protection des personnes
manquent toujours et là aussi c'est
grave monsieur le ministre il s'agissait
là d'un point essentiel de consensus de
notre commission et du Sénat tout entier
porté par nos deux rapporteurs
successifs Marie-Thérèse Hermange puis
jean-Pierre Godefroy la commission
regrette donc fortement que les mesures
réglementaires nécessaires se fassent
encore attendre enfin comme pour les
autres présidents notre bilan retrace
également le devenir des rapports devant
être remis au Parlement
ces demandes sans doute en nombre
excessifs sont d’intérêt inégal
certaines correspondent à une attente
légitime et nous souhaitons vivement
qu'ils soient données suite c'est le cas
notamment de la demande d'un bilan
annuel d'évaluation des emplois d'avenir
et d'un rapport sur l'accès à la justice
prud'homale que le Sénat avait souhaité
pour la fin 2013 à l'initiative de notre
collègue Claude Jeanneau pour conclure
monsieur le ministre vous constatez que
les membres de notre commission se sont
interrogées parfois avec irritation sur
la non-application de nombreuses
dispositions d'origine parlementaires
notre président de la commission
d'ailleurs saisi les ministres concernés
sur ce point
ces interrogations ne remettent pas en
cause le bilan positif que nous tirons
de la tendance continue à l'amélioration
de l'application des textes législatifs
tels qu'elle apparaît au travers de
notre suivi statistique
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Marie-Christine Blondin
président de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
mesdames la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président de la Commission comme chaque
année à la même période nous examinons
le bilan de la mise en application des
lois jusque la session écoulée 2012 2013
seuls trois lois relevant de la
Commission ont été adoptée pendant la
session contre 5 au cours de la
précédente mais autant la loi du 31
janvier visant à abroger la loi visant à
lutter contre l'absentéisme scolaire
issu d'une proposition de loi de notre
collègue Françoise Cartron était un
petit texte sur le plan du travail
législatif autant la loi pour la
refondation de l'école et la loi
relative à l'enseignement supérieur et à
la recherche sont placés parmi les
textes majeurs avec beaucoup
d'amendements et une discussion
approfondie les projets dont la
commission de la culture est saisi tente
toujours à se concentrer au début de la
législature de ce point de vue
l'activité constatée au cours de la
session 2012-2013 est tout à fait
comparable à la session
2007-2008 qui est le si suivez une année
d'élection présidentielle et législative
la loi abrogeant la loi sur
l'absentéisme scolaire et d'application
directe et donc applicable les lois
refondation de l'école et ESR sont
partiellement applicables pour mémoire
la loi sur la refondation de l'école
compte 89 articles et la loi ESR 129 un
certain nombre de ces dispositions ne
sont pas encore applicables mais ne le
seront pas avant plusieurs mois voire
quelques années je pense par exemple le
rapport annuel des organismes créés par
la loi telle le Conseil supérieur des
programmes
autre exemple la procédure de nomination
des présidents d'organismes de recherche
sans que soit intégralement mis en
oeuvre la méthode prévue par la loi il a
néanmoins été procédé à l'audition du
candidat pressenti en commission du
Sénat pour l'Inserm les décrets relatifs
au statut des organismes de recherche
n'ayant pas encore été modifié la loi
avsr peut être considérée comme mise en
application pour le quart de ces
dispositions alors que la loi sur la
refondation est pour les trois quarts
toutes deux ont été adoptés à la même
date la loi vs après application de la
procédure à accélérée la loi refondation
de l'école au terme du vote conforme du
Sénat en deuxième lecture le choix de la
procédure accélérée plutôt que celui de
laisser la navette se poursuivre et sans
aucun effet sur le rythme de publication
des mesures d'application pour la
refondation de l'école sur les 18
mesures prévues 12 ont été prises dans
le délai de six mois deux existait déjà
manque donc encore quatre mesures
d'application
en outre 15 mesures non prévues ont été
prises dans le décret du 7 janvier 2014
portant expérimentation d'une procédure
d'orientation des élèves disposition
introduite à l'initiative de notre
commission et des circulaires non prévus
relatives au dispositif d'initiation aux
métiers en alternance
au fond d'amorçage ou à la prévention de
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
s'agissant de la loi ESR sur les 29
mesures prévues 7 seulement ont été
prises dans un délai de six mois 22
manque encore à la pelle par ailleurs
quatre mesures non prévues ont été
prises et c'est avec stupéfaction
monsieur le ministre que j'ai découvert
un amendement du Gouvernement dans le
projet de loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et la forêt
entre vaches et cochons qui modifiait
les arbitrages du Parlement sur la loi
ESR parmi les mesures attendues et pour
faire écho un rapport remarqué de nos
collègues Dominique Giot et Michel
Maghreb je mentionnerai l'ordonnance qui
devrait être prise d'ici au 22 juillet
afin de définir les nouveaux contours du
système universitaire aux Antilles et en
sur 13 rapports prévus par la loi le
gouvernement a pris du retard pour l'un
d'entre eux déjà qui lui aussi
concernait une disposition introduite au
Sénat dans un délai de six mois après la
promulgation de la loi donc avant le 22
janvier 2014 le gouvernement devait
remettre un rapport formulant des
propositions en vue d'améliorer le mode
de sélection et de formation des futurs
médecins et d'élargir les origines
sociales et géographique des étudiants
il s'agissait de donner suite aux
recommandations de nos collègues de la
commission du développement durable en
matière de désertification médicale je
ne serai pas complète si je ne
mentionnais pas que deux des lois
promulgués au cours de la précédente
session sont entrées totalement en
application c'est la loi relative à la
rémunération pour copie privée et la
cependant faciliter l'organisation des
manifestations sportives et culturelles
toutes les mesures de l'application de
la loi relative à la communication
audiovisuelle et aux nouveaux services
publics de télévision
promulguez lors de la précédente
législature sont désormais parues autre
signe encourageant la parution d'un
décret d'application de la loi de
février 2012
visant à renforcer l'éthique du sport et
les droits des sportifs dernier point le
8 juillet 2013 a été publié un décret
d'application de la loi
relative à la protection pénale de la
propriété littéraire et artistique sur
internet
en clair la loi A2P ce texte a supprimé
la peine
contraventionnelle complémentaire de
suspension de l'accès à un service de
communication au public en ligne c'est
une réflexion potable qui appelle
néanmoins une vraie loi sur la société
numérique le partage et la rémunération
de la création en conclusion monsieur le
Président malgré une assiduité étiolée
et quelques présidents retenus je
voudrais ici saluer votre motivation et
votre sérieux pour mener à bien ce
travail et élaborer chaque année le
rapport mais il nous faudra des moyens
démocratiques d'alerter de façon plus
lisible le citoyen genre portail
Internet grand public façon Légifrance
car aujourd'hui quand on lit
attentivement le rapport c'est un peu le
miroir de notre impuissance et nous
avons besoin de la mobilisation
populaire pour exiger que les lois sont
appliquées et je vous encourage à
utiliser la capacité d'indignation dont
vous savez faire preuve pour dire à
Madame serao qu'il ne faut pas bouger
dans la loi agricole les arbitrages
obtenus au Parlement et à titre
personnel pour dire au gouvernement
qu'une loi sur les lanceurs d'alerte
pour éviter les conflits d'intérêts en
matière sanitaire 14 mois d'attente de
décret ça sent la protection des
intérêts merci
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
la parole est à michel Teston
vice-président de la commission du
développement durable
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission pour le contrôle
d'application des lois Mesdames et
Messieurs les présidents de commission
cher et chers collègues
je vous demande d'abord d'excuser
raymonval président de la Commission de
loin durable qui ne peut être présent
aujourd'hui
tiens d'abord à salué le travail de la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois sous
l'impulsion de son président David
Assouline qui a parfaitement synthétisé
dans son rapport les différentes
observations
formulées par nos commissions
permanentes ce travail est fondamental
car elle revient bien au Parlement de
s'assurer de la correcte mise en oeuvre
par le gouvernement des dispositions
légisatives que nous votons c'est la
deuxième fois mes chers collègues que la
commission du développement durable
dresse le bilan d'application des lois
dont le suivi lui incombe sur les six
lois promulgués au cours de l'année
parlementaire 2012-2013 dans les
secteurs relevant de la compétence de la
commission 2 sont issus de proposition
d'origine sénatoriale la loi du 24 avril
2013 relative à la progression du
mécanisme de l'éco-participation
répercuter à l'identique et affiché pour
les équipements électriques et
électroniques ménagers
issus d'une proposition de loi déposée
par notre collègue Gérard Michael la loi
du 13 avril 2013 relative à
l'indépendance de l'expertise en matière
de santé et d'environnement et à la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte
issus d'une proposition de loi déposée
par Marie-Christine Blandin et les
membres du groupe écologiste 22 mesures
d'application portant sur ces Chinois
ont été publiés entre le 1er octobre
2012 et de 31 mars 2014 dont 8 décrets
en Conseil d'État 7 décret simples cinq
arrêtés une ordonnance par ailleurs neuf
mesures d'application portant sur les
lois plus anciennes c'est-à-dire
promulguées avant le 1er octobre 2012
ont été publiés au cours de la même
période notre commission à relever avec
satisfaction que trois lois étaient
devenues totalement applicables entre le
premier octobre 2012 et le 31 mars 2014
grâce à l'adoption d'une ou plusieurs
des mesures d'application qui étaient
attendues
je cite la loi du 24 avril 2013
renforçant l'information des voyageurs
lors de la commercialisation des titres
de transport sur les compagnies
aériennes figurant sur la liste noire de
l'Union européenne la loi du 15 juin
2011 visant à faciliter la mise en
chantier des projets des collectivités
locales d'Île-de-France la loi du 5
janvier 2006 relative à la sécurité et
au développement des transports autre
motif de satisfaction aucune des lois
suivie par la commission durable n'était
totalement inapplicable au 31 mars 2014
ce qui devrait certes être normal mais
qui mérite d'être souligné compte tenu
de certains éléments passés enfin je
voudrais mentionner la mise en œuvre
d'une bonne pratique qui a permis
d'associer efficacement le Parlement au
suivi de l'application des lois la loi
du 27 décembre 2012 relative à la mise
en œuvre du principe de participation du
public défini à l'article 7 de la Charte
de l'environnement prévoyait une
ordonnance
à son article 12 pour transposer les
procédures de participation du public
aux collectivités territoriales et aux
décisions administratives individuelles
il fallait adapter dans ces deux cas les
formes et le niveau d'exigence de la
participation afin de ne pas alourdir
excessivement les procédures
à l'occasion de l'examen du texte en
sciences publiques nous étions émus que
la définition des règles applicables
collectivités territoriales échappe à
tout contrôle du Parlement il y a tout
débat avec les élus la ministre de
l'écologie d'abord Delphine bateau avait
pris l'engagement de transmettre aux
commissions permanente compétent de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat le
projet d'ordonnance avant sa publication
afin de nous permettre de formuler
d'éventuelles observations et bien cet
engagement a été tenu
le projet d'ornement sous a bien été
communiqué son examen a donné lieu à une
communication devant la commission
également durable de la rapporteur du
texte Laurence Rossignol et un débat sur
le contenu de l'ordonnance les éléments
soulevés à l'occasion de cette
discussion qui était transmis au
gouvernement d'une manière générale
notre commission a noté une amélioration
du taux d'application des lois
promulguées observez depuis quelques
années la prise de conscience par les
services ministériels de la nécessité
d'assurer une mise en oeuvre plus rapide
de la législation adoptée se trouve donc
confirmée toutefois plusieurs motifs
d'insatisfaction demeure
premièrement sur les Chinois adoptés au
cours de l'année parlementaire 2012-2013
et suivi par notre commission quatre on
était encore que partiellement
applicable au 31 mars 2014 la loi du 16
juillet 2013 portant diverses
dispositions d'adaptation aux droits de
l'Union européenne dans le domaine du
développement durable la loi du 28 mai
2013 portant diverses dispositions en
matière d'infrastructures et de services
de transport la loi du 16 avril 2013
relative à l'indépendance de l'expertise
en matière de santé d'environnement et à
la protection des lanceurs d'alerte la
loi du 27 décembre 2012 relative à la
mise en oeuvre du principe de
participation du public définit
l'article 7 de la Charte de
l'environnement
notre commission déplore en particulier
qu'au 31 mars 2014 c'est à dire un an
après son vote le premier volet de la
loi du 16 avril 2013 qui a créé la
Commission nationale de la déontologie
et des alertes en matière de santé
publique et d'environnement l'effet
l'objet d'aucune mesure réglementaire
d'application de même aucune des 37
mesures réglementaires d'application de
la partie modernisation du droit social
des gens de mer de la loi d'adules du 16
juillet 2013 n'était publiée au 31 mars
2014 nous avons encore en mémoire les
déclarations du gouvernement sur
l'urgence qu'il y avait un modernisation
droit social et l'administration avait
indiqué que les décrets étaient déjà en
préparation
deuxième observation près de 36% des
lois adoptées au cours des six dernières
années sont encore en attente de mesures
d'application troisièmement il est
regrettable de constater qu'aucun
rapport sur la mise en application des
lois suivies par la Commission de non
durable il a été transmis par le
gouvernement dans les Chinois suivant
leur entrée en vigueur le principe de
cette transmission et pourtant posé par
l'article 67 de la loi du 9 décembre
2004 de simplification du droit enfin
cette année encore nous pouvons déplorer
le retard voir l'absence de remise de
multiples rapports d'information
demandez au gouvernement en application
des dispositions négatives que nous
votons sur les 47 rapports certes ils
sont nombreux d'informations demander au
gouvernement depuis le 1er octobre 2003
à peine un peu plus de la moitié nous
ont été remis
aucun de l'année parlementaire 2012 2013
sur 3 rapports intéressants d'autres
commissions ont été transmis au Sénat
chez le ministre monsieur le Président
chers collègues comme vous le constatez
en dépit d'avancer notable de nombreux
progrès restent donc encore à faire pour
respecter l'objectif consistant à
prendre toutes les mesures
réglementaires nécessaires dans un délai
de 6 mois suivant la publication de
chaque loi objectif que le gouvernement
s'était assigné dans une circulaire de
merci
ni président de la commission des
finances
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la mission de contrôle de l'application
des lois est importante pour la
commission des finances et là était
particulièrement en 2013
car s'il faut reconnaître que nous
sommes saisis au fond de relativement
peu de textes par rapport à d'autres
commissions
cette année 18% des lois promulguées
cependant nous avons dû la même année
2013 contrôlée
40% des textes d'applications attendues
18% des textes 40% des textes
d'application
ce qui veut dire 190 mesures contre 118
l'année dernière bien entendu une
explication à cela c'est la loi bancaire
et
sur les mesures attendues
190 vous disaient 58% ont été prises
contre 76% l'année dernière
l'essentiel s'applique à la loi bancaire
dont le tour de mise en œuvre monsieur
le ministre n'est que de 20% des textes
d'applications attendues
pour ce qui est des rapports
d'application des lois seuls 4 ont été
remis il manque notamment celui relatif
à la loi bancaire
et sur 21 rapports demandés par le
Parlement 10 sont toujours en attente
alors j'en ai terminé mes chers
collègues n'ont pas avec mon propos mais
avec les chiffres
sur le fond alors je vois que une
certaine désillusion s'empare de
l'Assemblée mais sur le fond quelques
remarques doivent être formulées comme
toujours monsieur le ministre et vous le
savez puisque vous avez été un
parlementaire très présent dans
l'hémicycle du Palais Bourbon le
gouvernement quel qu'il soit mais peu
d'empressement à faire vivre des
dispositifs qui n'ont pas été adoptées à
son initiative il en va ainsi je prends
un exemple depuis 2011 de la TGAP sur
les sacs plastiques et plus
particulièrement sur les sacs de caisse
et nous avons l'intention d'ailleurs
d'y revenir avec un amendement dans le
prochain collectif budgétaire ensuite
nous avons assisté en 2013 à une
innovation qui est la réintroduction
alors ça c'est extraordinaire c'est la
réintroduction par voie de circulaire
d'une disposition de la loi de finances
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
c'est bien entendu par voie de
circulaire disposition censurée par le
Conseil constitutionnel il s'agissait
vous vous en souvenez de la prise en
compte de revenus non réellement perçue
par le contribuable pour le calcul du
plafonnement de l'ISSF
le Conseil constitutionnel a joué son
rôle il a immédiatement réagi mais j'ai
voulu souligner
cette pratique qui est vraiment à
l'extrême limite de ce que l'on peut
imaginer
en troisième lieu certains rapports
particulièrement attendus ne sont pas
remis en temps utiles au Parlement voir
ne sont jamais déposés ainsi le jaune
budgétaire sur l'application de notre
réseau de conventions fiscale
attendue avec le PLF 2014 n'a été remis
que le 4 avril 2014 et ne fournit aucune
explication sur le retrait de la liste
des États et territoires non coopératifs
de Jersey et des Bermudes sujets dans ce
souvient bien notamment notre excellente
collègue Nicole br qui fut très
attentive à ces sujets dans le passé
l'annexe au projet de loi de finance
relative à la mise en oeuvre par
l'administration fiscale des dispositifs
anti-abus par exemple en matière de prix
de transfert et de leur application
filière des entreprises françaises
détenus à l'étranger
cette annexe censée exister depuis 2009
nous l'attendons toujours alors je
conclurai par quelques considérations
relatives à la loi de séparation et de
régulation des activités bancaires loi
du 26 juillet 2013 dont je vous disais
tout à l'heure que seul 20% des textes
applications avaient été pris
cinq remarques si vous mis autorisez
encore première remarque comment
s'explique ce faible taux qui contraste
avec l'importance politique que le texte
semblait revêtir à l'époque aux yeux du
gouvernement deuxième remarque les
textes sur la résolution bancaire
c'est-à-dire sur la gestion des faillers
de bancaires ont été pris rapidement il
faut le reconnaître
ceci est-il dû monsieur le ministre à la
situation spécifique de Dexia et du
Crédit Immobilier de France
troisième remarque
c'est demain mardi le 1er juillet que
doit commencer le recensement des
activités qui devront être filialisées
au sein des groupes bancaires or le
décret d'application n'a pas été publié
alors monsieur le ministre sur quelle
base va pouvoir se faire cette
filialisation
quatrième remarque nous attendons
toujours le texte réglementaire relatif
à la publication dès 2014 de certaines
données relatives à la transparence des
activités pays par pays
et ce texte avait été en particulier de
mandé par vos amis politiques par vos
collègues ou camarades de groupes à
l'Assemblée nationale il n'est toujours
pas là quand ces données seront-elles
publiées et cinquième remarque la loi
bancaire comportait une disposition qui
préparait les banques à la collecte des
informations
relatives à
relative à la mise en oeuvre de l'accord
avec les États-Unis et pour ce qui est
de la loi américaine FATCA
mes chers collègues si cette législation
américaine FATCA prévoit que la première
transmission de données aura lieu en
septembre 2015
elle portera cette première transmission
sur des données collectées à compter du
30 juin 2014
aujourd'hui même or à ce jour lundi 30
juin le projet de loi de ratification de
l'accord n'a toujours pas été délibéré
en Conseil des ministres il n'y a donc
pas monsieur le ministre de fondement
juridique à la collecte de ces données
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus sur le
calendrier de ratification et sur la
manière dont on pourra être comblé se
vide juridique en matière de collecte
des données entre le 30 juin 2014 et la
date de ratification de l'accord cette
question mes chers collègues n'est pas
purement formelle c'est une question
hautement politique je me permets de le
souligner on ne peut pas appliquer FATCA
on ne peut pas ne pas appliquer FATCA en
raison du risque de retrait de leur
licence américaine pour les banques
françaises chacun le comprend avec la
décision qu'attendait au jour du même
BNP Paribas et que je persiste à titre
personnel à considérer comme tout à fait
scandaleuse mais dans le contexte de ce
contentieux et est-ce que nous ne
pouvons pas nous poser la question
suivante
et c'est ma dernière phrase
est-ce vraiment monsieur le ministre le
moment de donner tout ce qu'ils veulent
aux États-Unis alors qu'ils ont entamé
un comportement que je me permettrai de
qualifier de guerres monétaire dès lors
qu'il détienne le dollar seul monnaie
seule vraie monnaie de transactions du
monde et qu'ils peuvent en imprimer et
en émettre autant qu'ils veulent
ce pouvoir ce pouvoir menait terre cette
suprématie
doit-elle peut-elle est-il concevable
est-il convenable qu'elle soit détournée
à des fins de politique internationale
et pour servir la puissance d'un tel
état du monde fût-il effectivement le
plus puissant de tous les États du monde
merci mes chers collègues de votre
attention
merci monsieur le président de la
commission des finances j'appelle
jean-Pierre Sueur président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues
je pourrais vous dire bien entendu que
92% des lois promulguées au cours de la
période de référence sont devenus
applicables mais bien entendu ce
pourcentage de signifie à peu près rien
comme un certain nombre d'autres
pourcentages pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit
de 14 lois et qu'il y avait en dessous
12 mesures d'application donc vous voyez
bien que les pourcentage n'a pas de
signification
en revanche ce qui a une signification
c'est la grande charge de travail de la
commission des lois
en effet certains des textes que nous
avons
examinés
ne sont pas promulgués dans la période
mais si nous comptabilisons toutes les
situations possibles notre commission à
examiner au cours de la période
considérée 41 textes
et elle a produit 27 avis dont 21 avis
budgétaire donc nous avons une charge de
travail conséquente mais nous ne nous en
plaignons pas car ce travail est très
intéressant alors plutôt que de vous
faire un
exposé exhaustif sur ces sujets
nous nous avons j'ai choisi avec
l'approbation de la Commission de ne
traiter que d'un sujet qui est deux
points importants quant à l'application
d'une loi importante qui est la loi sur
le mariage des personnes de même sexe
le premier point que je voulais aborder
devant vous parce que ce sont des
problèmes extrêmement concrets
et relatif à la célébration d'un mariage
entre un français et un ressortissant
d'un pays n'autorisant pas le mariage
des personnes de même sexe est lié à la
France par une convention bilatérale
ce point a sans doute constitué la
principale difficulté rencontrer aux
deux mains au lendemain de l'adoption de
cette loi importante afin de garantir le
droit de se marier à tout Français y
compris lorsque son futur conjoint est
ressortissant d'un État qui ne reconnaît
pas le mariage entre personnes de même
sexe la loi introduit une nouvelle règle
de conflits des lois il s'agit de
l'article 2021 alinéa 2 du Code civil
permettant d'écarter la loi personnelle
de l'un des futurs époux qui
n'autoriserait pas l'union entre
personnes de même sexe cependant cette
règle de conflits des lois peut-être mis
en échec mes chers collègues en raison
du principe de hiérarchie des normes en
effet comme le rappelle la circulaire du
29 mai 2013 le deuxième alinéa de
l'article 2021 du Code civil ne pourrait
s'appliquer au ressortissants des pays
avec lesquels la France est liée par des
conventions bilatérales qui prévoit que
la loi applicable aux conditions de fond
du mariage et la loi personnelle de
chacun des époux dans la Dépêche du
premier roux 2013 diffusé au procureur
généraux le ministère de la Justice a
précisé qu'une distinction pouvait être
opérée entre les conventions qui
renvoient expressément à la loi
nationale de chacun des époux qui ne
pourrait être écartés et celles qui ne
vise que la situation des ressortissants
français qui pourraient donner lui une
interprétation plus souple cette analyse
a permis que soit envisagée
favorablement la célébration des
mariages concernant des ressortissants
du Laos du Cambodge de l'Algérie et de
la Tunisie
c'est dans ce contexte que sont
intervenus les premières décisions
judiciaires à ce sujet le tribunal de
grande instance de Chambéry a jugé le 11
octobre 2013 que le droit au mariage
pour les personnes de même sexe faisait
désormais partie de l'ordre public
international français qui permet au
juge d'écarter l'application d'une loi
étrangère incompatible avec les valeurs
et les droits fondamentaux français
malgré l'existence d'une convention
internationale contraire à laquelle la
France est partie il a ainsi écarté
l'application de l'article 5 de la
Convention franco-marocaine du 10 août
81 relative au statut des personnes et
de la famille et à la coopération
judiciaire qui prévoit que les
conditions de fond du mariage doivent
être appréciées au regard de la loi
personnelle de chacun des époux
la cour d'appel de Chambéry a confirmé
ce jugement dans un arrêt du 22 octobre
elle a considéré qu'il convenait
d'écarter l'application de la Convention
franco-marocaine au profit des principes
supérieures du nouvel ordre public
international
instaurée par la loi du 17 mai 2013
cette jurisprudence va plus loin que
l'interprétation de la règle de conflit
de loi donnée par la Dépêche du premier
roux 2013 mais cette décision fait
l'objet d'un pourvoi en cassation à
l'initiative du parquet général dont on
peut espérer que l'issue permette de
fixer la jurisprudence de sur cette
question mais j'appelle l'attention sur
un problème très délicat vous l'avez vu
qui est que même si la loi française
écarte en l'espèce l'application d'une
loi étrangère nous avons des traités et
conventions internationales qui
s'appliquent néanmoins et il peut y
avoir conflit entre deux ordres de
l'égalité la seconde question qui est
posée et celle de l'adoption
vous le savez mes chers collègues
l'adoption est désormais ouverte sous
toutes ses formes dans les conditions
prévues par le titre 8 du Code civil à
tous les couples mariés qu'ils soient
homosexuels ou hétérosexuel à ce jour
les seuls cas d'adoption dont ont eu à
connaître les tribunaux concernent des
hypothèses d'adoption de l'enfant du
conjoint le cas de figure le plus
fréquent et dans celui d'une femme se
rendant à l'étranger pour faire l'objet
d'une insémination artificielle la
conjointe sollicitant ensuite des
juridictions françaises l'adoption de
l'enfant ces questions relèvent de
l'appréciation des tribunaux le juge
reste en seul compétent pour décider
d'une adoption qui selon l'article 353
du Code civil ne peut être prononcé que
si les conditions de la loi sont
remplies et si l'adoption est conforme à
l'intérêt de l'enfant le tribunal de
grande instance de Lille
a été la première juridiction française
a autorisé par jugement en date du 14
octobre 2013 l'adoption à la forme
plénière par une épouse en application
de la loi du 17 mai 2013 de deux enfants
de sa conjointe depuis d'autres
juridictions ont suivi cet exemple en
particulier les juridictions de Toulouse
et de Limoges mais
un refus d'adoption a été prononcé par
le tribunal de grande instance de
Versailles dans une décision du 30 avril
2013 cette juridiction a refusé
l'adoption d'un enfant conçu par le
biais d'un protocole d'assistance
médicale à la procréation
réalisé en Belgique par l'épouse de sa
mère au motif de fraude à la loi
cette position ne semble pas être
majoritaire si on prend en compte les
diverses décisions des juridictions
mais il y a la véritable problème en
matière d'assistance médicale à la
procréation contrairement à la gestation
pour autrui il n'y a pas de prohibition
d'ordre public le seul fait de recourir
à l'assistance médicale à la procréation
à l'étranger ne serait donc pas
contraire à un principe essentiel du
droit français et ne constituerait pas
en soi une fraude à la loi susceptible
de fonder le refus d'une adoption par le
conjoint au demeurant madame la
Présidente je termine rien ne permet de
savoir qu'un enfant est issu d'une
assistance médicale à la procréation et
encore moins d'une assistance médicale à
la procréation réalisée à l'étranger
aucune mention ne figurant à cet égard
sur l'acte civil de l'enfant si un
tribunal s'oppose à l'adoption de sur ce
fondement c'est que les parents l'ont
indiqué dans la procédure j'ai choisi
ces exemples pour montrer que
l'application de la loi est aussi
en l'espèce soumise à des décisions de
justice qui peuvent être différentes les
unes des autres et auxquelles nous
devons également prêter notre attention
je vous remercie d'avoir bien voulu
écouter ce propos sur cet aspect
particulier mais non négligeable de
l'application des lois je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes madame mélian
assassin madame la Présidente vous avez
la parole groupe CRC vous pouvez venir
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues notre débat de cet après-midi
à le mairie de Portet au coeur du débat
public cette question de l'application
des lois si la démocratie passe par le
vote de la loi par les représentants du
peuple au sein des assemblées
parlementaires l'exercice effectif de la
démocratie doit se traduire dans la mise
en application des lois votées c'est
dire donc
s'il faut accorder de l'importance aux
travaux de la commission que préside de
notre collègue David Assouline et c'est
aussi pour la raison pour laquelle c'est
la présidente de mon gouv qui a fait le
choix d'être présente cet après-midi à
ce débat alors
le débat de l'année dernière nous
démontrer que le taux de mise en
application des lois de la session
ordinaire était de 65%, il était alors
en progression de 20% par rapport à
l'année précédente donc ce taux cela a
été dit quasiment le même pour 2012-2013
le rapport semble indiquer une
progression sur la 14e législature avec
88% mais ce chiffre demandera à être
confirmé bien évidemment lors du
prochain rapport
monsieur Assouline l'a dit mais le seul
taux d'application dont on pourrait se
satisfaire vers c'est celui de 100 %
selon un principe tout simple toute loi
voté doit être appliquée l'application
des lois est un lien est en lien direct
avec le principe démocratique cela est
d'autant plus vrai que l'on constate que
le taux d'application des lois
d'initiative parlementaire est plus
faible encore que celui d'initiative
gouvernementale et que celui-ci diminue
encore quand il s'applique au Sénat
ainsi la non-application des lois
revient à ne pas reconnaître les droits
du Parlement et constituent aussi une
manière pour les gouvernements de
récupérer la main ce phénomène malmène a
fortiori les droits des groupes
parlementaires qui n'appartiennent pas à
la majorité qui ne disposent pour
valoriser leurs initiatives que des
espaces dédiés aux propositions de loi
qui en plus en plus d'être rare peuvent
être qualifiés d'inutiles si ces
dernières ne sont jamais édictées sous
forme de décret
en ce qui concerne les rapports du
Gouvernement au Parlement prescrit par
la loi malheureusement là encore la
situation n'a pas changé elle reste
infligeante puisque ces rapports sont
rarement rendus et pourtant ils sont
utiles puisque censés permettre au
Parlement de pouvoir exercer un contrôle
sur l'action du gouvernement alors quant
aux études d'impact les fameuses études
d'impact
je rappelle qu'elles sont une obligation
constitutionnelle mais nous pouvons
constater qu'elles sont rarement
complètes quelquefois
erronées et trop souvent considéré comme
facultatif pourtant elle doit figurer en
annexe de chaque projet de loi pour
apprécier les conséquences concrètes de
ces textes et mesurer leur impact
financier cela permet de contrôler
l'effectivité des textes législatifs
pour nos concitoyens en mettant en
relation les lois et les moyens alloués
à la loi toutefois plus largement je
pense que la question de l'effectivité
réelle des lois a beaucoup pas voir avec
les conditions dans lesquelles celle-ci
sont présentées et adoptées alors je
voudrais revenir ici sur un point
souligner par ce rapport c'est la
procédure accélérée qui ne favorise
nullement l'entrée en vigueur plus
rapidement
des textes de loi
cette procédure nuit à la qualité des
textes elle ne se elle ne sert que trop
souvent des objectifs politiques pour
éviter les deux lectures dans les deux
assemblées ou bien gagner du temps sur
un calendrier trop rempli car cela non
plus n'a pas changé nous continuons de
faire face à une avalanche de texte qui
peine à trouver leur place dans un
calendrier chargé menant désormais à des
sessions qui n'ont plus
d'extraordinaires que leur nom pourtant
il est une exigence essentielle celle de
stabilité de sécurité et de lisibilité
de la loi pour les citoyens notre
législation est sur bien des points est
devenu peu lisible cette avalanche des
textes quand ceci entre en vigueur
compromet ensuite la capacité des
magistrats à appliquer la loi et cela
met également en cause le principe de
l'égalité de nos concitoyens devant une
loi qu'ils sont censés connaître mais
chers collègues le contrôle de
l'application des lois et donc la
question importante puisqu'elle
sous-tend l'effectivité des principes
démocratiques et constitutionnels de
notre République et je remercie donc
notre collègue David Assouline président
de la commission sénatoriale pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois pour
tout le travail qu'il entreprend avec
disons-le une certaine ténacité il a
tout à fait raison pour autant il me
semble que beaucoup restent à faire et
je ne saurais
capeler le gouvernement a enfin écouté
cette commission en prenant en compte
les conclusions de ce rapport pour
améliorer cette application je vous
remercie merci Madame assassy la parole
est à notre collègue Nathalie Goulay du
groupe udi UC
oui je vais le faire madame le Président
Monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues
il ennuie vient de l'uniformité
le bilan annuel de l'application des
lois c'est un peu
absolument
merci je disais donc que le bilan de
l'application des lois c'est un peu
comme le patinage artistique sur France
2 le dimanche et les figures imposées et
puis des figures libres nous avons fini
avec les présidents des commissions les
imposées voilà donc les figures libres
je vais vous donc vous éviter les
chiffres qui ont déjà été
cités et en dépit d'un riche rapports et
dense surtout dans la deuxième partie
rapport qui finalement est entaché des
mêmes vis que ce qu'il dénonce
c'est-à-dire qui nous est parvenu le 26
juin c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'ait
pas eu un peu avant pour le préparer et
oui je sais mais en même temps trois
jours avant la séance c'est un peu c'est
un peu compliqué à étudier tout cela est
d'autant plus dommage que cette
commission sénatoriale semble faire
doublon avec les commissions permanentes
le premier alinéa de l'article 22 de
notre règlement est formel sur ce point
le suivi de l'application des lois une
compétence des commissions permanence et
c'est pas un hasard si chacun des
présidents des présidents des
commissions permanentes sont venues nous
exposer leur avis et donc dès lors que
le chapitre 10 de l'instruction générale
du bureau
expose ce problème nous pourrions très
bien je crois revoir l'existence de
cette commission
d'autant plus d'autant plus que si on
doit oui écouter c'est mon droit
d'autant plus que si d'autant plus que
si nous parlons de commission et de
délégation dans le même moment le
président du Sénat s'est opposé à une
demande commune de l'ensemble de la
commission chargée des problèmes
d'évasion fiscale et sur proposition de
notre excellent rapporteur Éric Bocquet
pour avoir une délégation permanente
poursuivie pour suivre les problèmes
d'évasion et de fraude fiscale donc
entre
le suivi des lois la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale je pense que notre règlement et
le travail des commissions permanentes
aurait pu suffire quoi qu'il en soit le
gouvernement nous sollicite
régulièrement pour des ordonnances de
simplification j'ai le bonheur et le
privilège de représenter un département
présidé par le président Alain Lambert
qui nous parle tous les jours de
l'avalanche de norme et donc nous sommes
dans une situation assez intéressante ou
d'un côté on veut supprimer des normes
mais ou celle qui sont nécessaires ne
sont pas en place et donc évidemment je
pense que tout ça a deux rapports le
premier avec la qualité de la loi et
l'excellent présidentielle qui vient de
nous quitter pendant un moment vient de
présider un rapport sur l'écriture enfin
colloque sur l'écriture de la loi
et le Conseil constitutionnel nous
rappelle d'ailleurs très souvent les
conditions pour que la loi soit bonne ça
ne nous empêche pas
donc ce problème de rédaction de la loi
est effectivement extrêmement important
entre 2012 et 2013 30 lois promulguées
manque des décrets d'applications 5 sont
en points morts notamment l'interdiction
du bisphédra dans on va parler tout à
l'heure comme étant un problème lié au
réglementations européennes oui
peut-être mais en attendant c'est un
problème sanitaire
11% des mesures réglementaires de la loi
de financement de sécurité sociale pour
2013 donc toujours pas vu le jour alors
que nous allons peut-être aborder le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
de sécurité sociale pour 2014 même
problème en matière de loi de finances
cette mesure d'application du collectif
de 2012 de son jamais sortis notamment
sur la traçabilité du tabac ce qui est
quand même relativement important et je
ne parle pas du problème extrêmement
important monsieur le ministre d'une
d'une réforme qui était celle des
donneurs d'alerte parce que non
seulement sur ce point de vue là et sur
ce sujet important nous n'avons pas une
réglementation uniforme mais épars non
seulement nous n'avons pas de définition
du lanceur d'alerte non seulement nous
n'avons absolument pas d'efficacité de
la mesure puisque certains lanceurs
d'alerte viennent encore d'être
licenciés mais en plus les décrets
d'application
n'apparaissent pas et j'en aurai presque
terminé madame le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en vous parlant de l'action de
groupe que nous avons eu beaucoup de
difficultés à voir imposées j'ai été
vice-président de la commission
d'enquête sur le Médiator la même chose
sur un certain nombre de procédures
cette action de groupe permettrait quand
même de faciliter un certain nombre de
procédures pour des gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens de poursuivre un par un des
groupes notamment pharmaceutiques dont
vous savez très bien les difficultés que
représentent le coût de la justice donc
chacun vient ici vous apporter son petit
lot de lamentation par rapport à ces
préoccupations mais très franchement
cette action de groupe doit pouvoir
enfin rentrer dans notre droit positif
alors j'en aurai pratiquement terminé
en vous disant que en ce qui concerne
les conventions internationales
en ce qui concerne les conventions
internationales c'est à la marge mais
les conventions internationales vous
avez siéger à l'Assemblée parlementaire
du Conseil de l'Europe vous savez très
bien que la qualité est le de la France
et sa reconnaissance dans les
institutions internationales passent
aussi par le fait qu'en dehors de donner
des leçons et d'illuminer la planète on
peut aussi respecter les conventions
internationales et si nous ne les
ratifions pas ça pose un certain nombre
de problèmes donc ces problèmes sont
maintenus certaines conventions sont
dans les limbes entre l'assemblé
nationale et le Sénat voir entre le Quai
des Brumes l'Assemblée nationale et le
Sénat pour plus de 11 ans alors j'ai une
liste j'ai une liste ici bon je pourrais
vous la communiquer si cela vous vous
intéresse et je voudrais cette fois-ci
vraiment terminée en vous disant que
parfois et Daniel Renner on a parlé tout
à l'heure quand on demande des rapports
les parlementaires ça ferait bien
pourquoi ils le font et vous avez été
parlementaire vous savez très bien
depuis 2007 je me bats par exemple pour
un problème totalement inintéressant des
ambassadeurs thématiques on a demandé un
rapport on l'a toujours pas eu et donc
non seulement on ne sait pas combien il
coûte mais en plus on continue à en
nommer c'est à dire qu'on est un
phénomène absolument permanent de
recyclage des amis en mal d'exotisme un
problème de recyclage systématique
d'obliger alimentaire de la République
dans notre dans notre pays ne peut plus
supporter les coûts et en revanche
Daniel Renner a donc parlé de ce rapport
remis à la Commission de la Défense par
votre collègue Le Drian sur la mise en
place de la loi de programmation
militaire absolument remarquable et tout
à fait utile à nos travaux nous pourrons
ainsi suivre
j'espère là progression de cette mise en
place on évitant les gels et les surgels
dont nous pouvons éventuellement
craindre qu'il n'affecte la mise en
place de cette programmation militaire
donc évidemment l'application de la loi
est un c'est oui et oui ça vous ennuie
mais j'en ai terminé je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté merci Madame Roulet la
parole est à Philippe Kaltenbach du
groupe socialiste
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues
je veux tout d'abord ici saluer le
travail accompli cette année par la
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois et je veux
également féliciter son président David
Assouline qui s'est investit avec force
et rigueur dans cet instant depuis sa
création et puis je veux également
remercier tous les membres de cette
commission qui s'investissent pour la
faire vivre et rendre des rapports qui
je crois contribuent à faire en sorte
que nos lois soient mieux appliquées
le Sénat ne peut considérer son rôle
achevé une fois la loi votée ils doivent
veiller à la réelle application de la
loi et ensuite le cas échéant vérifiez
les conditions d'application de celle-ci
je crois que nous pouvons tous être
d'accord sur ces principes
d'ailleurs dès 1971 le Sénat c'est doté
d'un outil informatique la base appleg
qui permet aux commissions permanentes
de recenser au fur et à mesure de
l'apparition les décrets et les rapports
d'application des lois dont elles ont
assuré la préparation
en 2011 le Sénat a décidé d'aller encore
plus loin en mettant en place cette
commission sénatoriale pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois entièrement
dédié à cette mission
je tiens d'ailleurs à souligner que nous
faisons figure d'exception en Europe
avec le Royaume-Uni qui lui aussi a mis
en place une commission Haddock commune
aux deux chambres
en règle générale le contrôle de
l'application des lois est réalisé par
les commissions permanentes
l'administration ou encore le
gouvernement
mesurons donc la portée symbolique et
institutionnelle de la création en
France de la commission sanatoriale pour
le pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois je crois que nous pouvons en être
collectivement fiers et d'ailleurs
j'espère que je suis même certain que
cette commission perdurera après le
revenant de septembre j'ai compris que
Madame Goulet était opposée mais je
crois qu'elle sera peut-être isolée sur
ce point pourtant et je veux le rappeler
ici lorsque cette commission a été créée
nombreux étaient les sceptiques
aujourd'hui son utilité ne fait plus
aucun doute et son action est reconnue
la Commission entend contribue à
l'émergence au Sénat d'une véritable
culture du contrôle et de l'évaluation
les sénateurs socialistes considèrent
que la bonne mise en application des
lois est essentielle pour notre
démocratie pour redonner à nos
concitoyens confiance dans l'activité
législative et dans le système politique
la loi représente la première condition
de l'égalité républicaine de fait si la
loi n'est pas appliquée faute de décret
faute de moyens alors le lien qui unit
les Français se délitent et le discrédit
vis-à-vis de la politique croit
c'est pour cela que le Sénat ne peut se
contenter de voter la loi il doit
exercer un contrôle sur la manière dont
les lois sont appliquées
le rapport annuel qui nous a été
présenté montre une évolution positive
parce qu'on se base sur l'analyse
l'analyse quantitative en effet le taux
de mise en application des mesures
législatives de la session atteint
65%. à titre indicatif les taux observés
jusqu'en 2009 2010 était très faible
entre 10 et 35%
. la progression est donc significative
et les premières statistiques
disponibles confirment cette orientation
positive pour l'actuelle 14e législature
avec environ 88% des lois déjà mises en
application partielle ou totale
la mise en application des lois est une
priorité forte du gouvernement depuis le
début du quinquennat
malheureusement je crois qu'il faut le
rappeler tel n'était pas le cas sous la
précédente législature je vais prendre
un seul exemple celui de la
pénitentiaire de novembre 2009 les
premiers décrets d'application sont
intervenus un an après l'adoption du
texte par le Parlement et ce sont par la
suite échelonnés sur toute la durée de
la fin du quinquennat et
il n'avait pas tous été pris en 2012
la garde des sceaux Christian tobira qui
était dans ce même cycle jeudi dernier
rappelait à cette occasion qu'en mai
2012 de décrets de cette loi n'avait
toujours pas été pris un rapport entre
collègues le cerf lavait d'ailleurs
pointé insuffisance de moyens inertie
administratif manque de volonté
politique autant de prétextes qui ont
fait que cette loi n'a pas été à la
mesure des espoirs qu'elle a pu soulever
et qu'il a fallu attendre donc un
nouveau garde des sourds madame Taubira
pour que tous les décrets puissent enfin
être pris et malheureusement cet exemple
n'est pas unique
à partir de juin 2012 le gouvernement de
Jean-Marc Ayrault a dû mettre en
application un certain nombre de lois
hérités de la majorité précédente et
j'ai été très heureux que notre actuel
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
Jean-Marie Le Guen réitère l'engagement
du gouvernement quant à la bonne
application des lois lors de cette lors
de son audition par la commission
sénatoriale
je profite d'ailleurs de cette occasion
pour répondre à une attaque que je
qualifie un petit peu de sournoise
puisque certains voudraient nous faire
croire que la multiplication des
abonnements votés en séance que ce soit
au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée entraînerait
derrière une avalanche de demande de
texte réglementaires et que ce sont les
amendements votés par les parlementaires
qui seraient responsables de
l'allongement des délais pour la prise
des décrets je crois qu'il ne faut pas
chercher de mauvaises excuses le pouvoir
d'amender fait partie des droits et
prérogatifs des parlementaires c'est
indispensable d'autant que nous n'avons
pas beaucoup il faut bien le dire de
possibilités pour faire évoluer les lois
donc nous utilisons bien sûr cette
possibilité d'amender qui ensuite
nécessite parfois des décrets mais je
crois que c'est au gouvernement de tenir
compte de ce que vote le Parlement et de
prendre les décrets dans les délais qui
s'imposent
j'ai noté dans le rapport présenté par
David Assouline de données sur
lesquelles il convient de mettre un
accent particulier tout d'abord les taux
et délais de mise en application des
textes issus de l'initiative
parlementaire ça a été dit à plusieurs
reprises à cette tribune délai qui sont
pour le moins nettement inférieur à ce
des textes
issus du gouvernement
bien que la réforme conditionnelle de
2008 est permis de Sains évolutions et
par ailleurs et je le note aussi avec
beaucoup de regrets le fait que les
textes issus de Sénats soient traités de
manière moins favorable que ceux issues
de l'Assemblée n'est pas acceptable il y
aurait-il une discrimination à
l'encontre du Sénat bien sûr je ne veux
pas le croire d'ailleurs Jean-Marie Le
Guen ministre des Relations avec le
Parlement lors de l'audition à laquelle
j'ai fait référence nous a rassurer car
il a jugé qu'une telle différence était
inacceptable néanmoins même si nous
avons l'appui du ministre je crois que
c'est à nous sénateur de demeurer
extrêmement vigilant
contrôler l'application des lois ce
n'est pas simplement une affaire de
comptabilité même si c'est indispensable
il faut tenir le décompte des décrésies
et des décréments pris mais le plus
important c'est l'évaluation
et le travail qui est réalisé par la
commission que préside avec brio David
Assouline est à cet égard remarquable
puisque un nombre important de rapports
sont rendus régulièrement à chaque fois
confié un binôme de rapporteur de
sensibilité politique différente le
point de vue adopté est donc élargi et
confère plus d'impartialité assez
rapports l'objectif est de préparer de
faciliter le travail législatif du Sénat
on lui fournissant des bilans sur
l'application de législation en vigueur
notamment celle que le gouvernement se
propose de modifier
j'ai ainsi été rapporteur avec ma
collègue mugadini
d'un rapport sur l'application des
dispositions de la loi du 4 août 2008
relative à la création de
l'auto-entrepreneur
d'ailleurs le rapport que nous avons
rendu je crois a permis une évolution
du texte Pinel qui au début était
défavorable à l'auto-entrepreneur et qui
a évolué dans un sens plus équilibré et
puis actuellement je travaille avec
Jacqueline Gouraud sur l'évaluation des
dispositifs législatifs récents sur la
lutte contre la précarité dans la
fonction publique et l'intégration des
contractuels ces rapports pour l'objet
de faire le point sur les évolutions
législatives et de proposer des
recommandations
vous le constatez votre commission a
adopter une approche résolument
qualitative en effet une application de
la loi peut aussi résulter de
dispositifs mal adaptés trop ambitieux
ou dans les effets n'avaient pas été
convoitables incontournablement anticipé
nombreuses questions se posent les
moyens nécessaires ont-ils été déployés
la loi a-t-elle répondu aux attentes qui
justifiaient sont d'adoption faut-il
aujourd'hui l'abroger la modifier si tel
est le cas dans quelle direction
autant de points qui font que l'enjeu de
mieux légiférer c'est aujourd'hui
l'objet d'une prise de conscience
croissante de la part de l'ensemble des
sénateurs et je l'espère au-delà
à ce propos je me félicite de constater
que cette prise de conscience est aussi
valable en ce qui concerne
l'amélioration des normes des
collectivités territoriales en effet le
17 octobre dernier un conseil national
en charge de l'évaluation des normes
applicables aux collectivités
territoriales a été créée à l'initiative
du Sénat et je tiens à saluer le travail
de nos collègues jean-Pierre Sueur et
Jacqueline Gourault qui avait déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens en
décembre 2012 c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour solutionner le problème de
l'excès de norme aussi bien du point de
vue de leur volume que de leur
complexité et c'est particulièrement
attendu par les maires et les Aigles
locaux pour conclure j'aimerais vous
dire mes chers collègues qu'il est
aujourd'hui indispensable de développer
des bases de données ouvertes qu'on
appelle Open Data pour que l'information
soit accessible à tous
cela va dans le sens voulu par votre
commission permettre à tous aux citoyens
aux associations de suivre le travail
parlementaire et gouvernemental nous le
savons aujourd'hui certains sites
recensent notre activité et sont
régulièrement consultés il ne serait pas
illogique que la publication des textes
d'applications fassent l'objet de la
même vigilance citoyenne et cela
pourrait être efficace et venir
renforcer le travail de la commission
sur l'application des lois l'ouverture
de ces données renforcerait la
transparence améliorer le contrôle des
citoyens et favoriserait leur
mobilisation
j'encourage donc le gouvernement à
s'inscrire en cette dynamique le plus
rapidement possible
enfin je
pars frais Montesquieu en vous disant
que les décrets oubliés affaiblissent
les lois nécessaires et nous comptons
sur le gouvernement sur vous monsieur le
ministre des relations que le Parlement
mais également sur l'ensemble des
ministres pour faire en sorte que les
lois votées par le Parlement rentrent
bien en application et puis ensuite pour
tenir compte de l'évaluation des lois
qui pourraient être réalisées ici au
Sénat je vous remercie je vous remercie
chers collègues la parole est à Corinne
bouchoud du groupe écologiste
madame la présidente Madame et Monsieur
les présidentes commissions monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre les
chiffres intéressants tous étaient cités
les remarques pertinentes ont tout été
faites et donc je vais utiliser les
quelques minutes qui me sont partis pour
faire quelques remarques peut-être un
petit peu iconographe qui vont rejoindre
la remarque de la présidente Blandin sur
le miroir de notre impuissance
nous votons des lois nous travaillons
énormément si l'on accumulait le nombre
d'heures de travail c'est tout à fait
colossal nous votons beaucoup de lois
nous votons beaucoup d'amendements même
si ça a été dit seulement 24% des
amendements d'origine sénatoriale sont
suivies des faits ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que simplement un quart de nos
amendements sont effectifs
si on prend un exemple récent d'une
d'une mission qui a été faite suite à
cette commission le travail qu'a porté
sur l'application de la loi Morin sur
l'indemnisation des victimes des essais
nucléaires ce rapport a été suivi des
faits puisque la programmation doit
militaire a permis de modifier un aspect
de cette loi qui paraissait
particulièrement contre-productive six
mois après la modification législative
qui devait améliorer les choses donc
cela fait écho à notre travail
doublement il ne s'est toujours rien
passé les associations de victimes se
désespèrent de voir une évolution et
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de franchises
quelqu'un de très compétent au cabinet
du ministre m'a dit nous avons modifié
la loi mais il ne faut pas ouvrir la
boîte de Pandore et je pense que ça
résume assez bien le travail que nous
faisons ici pour moi la question n'est
pas est ce que les lois que nous votons
sont efficaces ou pas c'est simplement
est-ce que le travail que fait la Haute
Assemblée est utile ou pas et à cet
égard je voudrais signaler que les
rapports qui sont produits par notre
commission sont utilisées de façon
extrêmement intéressante dans université
et un certain nombre d'universitaires
voient à l'appui de ce travail la
théorie suivant laquelle la Haute
Assemblée ne sert plus à rien à mon avis
cette vision là doit être prise en
compte donc si on regarde ce que dit le
rapport de cette année on constate que
dans la moitié des cas notre travail ne
sert à rien dans la moitié des cas de
cette moitié là les décrets ne sont pas
suivi des faits et lorsque l'on regarde
la réalité aujourd'hui le chômage peine
à baisser les Français sont les
champions du monde de la consommation
des antidépresseurs et là tout le monde
est pressé d'aller regarder le match de
foot en espérant que la France va gagner
et qu'un miracle va s'opérer que cela va
un petit peu redonner du moral à tout le
monde donc moi la question que j'ai un
petit peu envie de poser lorsqu'on voit
le travail dans cette commission c'est
qu'il est utile dans la mesure où il
permet à des sénateurs de commission
différents de travailler ensemble ici
nous travaillons dans des silos les
commissions travaillent les unes à côté
des autres et l'intérêt principal de
cette commission et de faire travailler
ensemble des sénateurs le travail dans
des commissions différentes et cela nous
permet de voir que les problèmes sont
complexes c'est que la transversalité
est extrêmement importante donc en ce
sens et aussi je dirais contenu de
l'énergie qui met le Président il nous
semble que cette commission est
intéressante en tant que méthode de
travail en tant qu'échange de la
pratique en tant qu'interrogation sur
notre utilité et sur notre sens
néanmoins lorsque nous regardons l'année
écoulé lorsque nous regardons cette
année avec des lunettes écologistes on
ne peut qu'être un petit peu déçu pour
ne pas dire très déçu des textes qui ont
été appliqués nous avons été extrêmement
déçus de la lenteur avec laquelle les
textes sur les lanceurs d'alerte ont été
suivies des faits les décrets viennent
tout juste de sortir actuellement et
donc si le bilan de l'année écoulé est
extrêmement demi-taintes nous aimerions
y voir plutôt une promesse pour l'avenir
c'est à dire que nous espérons
nous espérons que les points de vue que
nous avons défendu nous espérons que les
idéaux auxquels nous croyons nous
espérons que tout cela sera un peu plus
pris en compte et nous voyons en fait ce
travail de cette commission comme tout à
fait illustratif de la crise de notre
régime actuellement d'un système où le
Parlement peine à se faire entendre ou
sauf à se rouler par terre et à menacer
de ne pas voter un budget on n'existe
pas et nous voyons bien que ce travail
de grande qualité montre les limites de
notre système actuel et nous appelons de
nos vœux une réflexion collective sur
une évolution de la Cinquième République
et nous espérons que les conclusions
faites par les différents présidents de
commissions seront entendus qu'on passe
de l'impuissance à l'efficacité c'est
tout ce que nous attendons et nous vous
remercions de votre attention merci
chers collègues dernière intervenant
inscrit dans la discussion générale
Christophe André frassat du groupe UMP
merci monsieur le Président au moins
deux
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président chers
collègues notre mission d'évaluation des
politiques publiques est indispensable
évaluer le pouvoir exécutif c'est le
contrôler il s'agit de faire respecter
un principe fondateur de notre
République démocratique la séparation
équilibrée des pouvoirs je ne peux ainsi
que me réjouir du travail que vous avez
mené monsieur le Président et
reconnaître son utilité même si
davantage d'objectivité de neutralité eu
cet été appréciable quoi qu'il en soit
votre vos travaux vise à remplir
l'objectif d'amélioration de nos
institutions en mettant en exergue les
dysfonctionnements qui convient de
régler et cet objectif est rempli le
rapport révèle plusieurs obstructions
gouvernementales ayant pour conséquence
de restreindre nos prérogatives
parlementaires d'affaiblir la qualité du
travail législatif et de porter atteinte
au droit de nos concitoyens chers
collègues nous ne pouvons accepter de
telles entraves nous devons ensemble
contraindre le gouvernement à respecter
ses obligations constitutionnelles nous
devons notamment avoir suffisamment de
temps pour l'analyse des textes et de
leurs effets disposer de l'ensemble des
données existantes et assurer le respect
du travail législatif monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai relevé
trois catégories de problématiques il
est urgent de résoudre afin de rétablir
l'équilibre dans nos institutions
démocratiques que l'on appartiennent à
l'opposition ou non d'ailleurs
premièrement nos droits et nos devoirs
de parlementaires se voient trop souvent
limiter et ce n'est pas tolérable vous
reprochez à la précédente majorité
d'utiliser de façon excessive la
procédure accélérée aussitôt au pouvoir
nous constatons que vous persévérez dans
cette voie malgré vos critiques
d'autrefois de plus le rapport précise
que la procédure est trop souvent
actionnée à mauvais escient si le
gouvernement invoque l'urgence pour
l'utilisation de la procédure accélérée
il semble que cette urgence disparaisse
à l'issue du vote puisque l'on constate
en retard considérable dans la parution
des degrés d'application j'ai d'ailleurs
pointé cette incohérence en citant
l'exemple de la loi du 22 juillet 2013
relative à la représentation des
Français établir de France dont les
décrets sont parus huit mois après et
surtout c'est ça qui est le plus
important six jours avant la date limite
de dépôt des candidatures pour les
élections les élections consulaires
découlant de cette réforme par ailleurs
l'attente que nous l'atteinte pardon que
nous porte le gouvernement était
également lié à la médiocre qualité des
documents qui sont mis à notre
disposition s'il est vrai que nous
demandons trop de rapports leurs
qualités ne doit pas pour autant être
affectée il en est de même pour les
études d'impact qui conditionnent la
suite de nos travaux prenons encore un
exemple frappant l'étude d'impact de la
réforme territoriale dont le contenu est
insignifiant et qui n'apporte aucune
donnée concrète sur les effets réels du
projet de réforme gouvernementales dans
ces circonstances comment sommes-nous
censés nous positionner comment juger du
bien fondé d'une telle réforme aux
objectifs emblématiques lorsque les
conséquences sont inconnues car non
évaluées mais surtout comment vous-mêmes
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous être
convaincus de son effectivité lorsque
les suites sont inconnues ce flou total
nous prive des moyens de construire un
cadre légal solide et cohérent notre
droit d'évaluer l'action du gouvernement
en est limité la teinte manifeste au
pouvoir du législateur apparaît
également dans la publication des
circulaires bactérienne ces circulaires
sont réputés ce borné à l'interprétation
stricte de la loi mais que le
gouvernement détourne de leur esprit dès
lors vous négligez la hiérarchie des
normes principes définissant l'État de
droit deuxième point vous traitez les
parlementaires de façon inégale alors
même que nous sommes tous des
représentants de la nation c'est
inégalité apparaît d'une part dans la
parution des décrets d'applications de
loi curieusement plus rapide lorsqu'il
s'agit des lois issues de l'initiative
gouvernementale de fait le gouvernement
instaure une priorité entre les lois
qu'il soutient et les autres d'autre
part le gouvernement effectue une
préférence entre les lois votées à
l'initiative de l'Assemblée nationale et
celle à l'initiative du Sénat du Sénat
qui sont mises au second plan pourquoi
est-ce au nom d'un bicaméralisme
inégalitaire
troisième point le rapport indique que
le choc de simplification annonçait
s'est transformé en choc de
complexification
non seulement avec une inflation
normative mais également avec des
projets de loi de plus en plus
technocratiques ambigu et
incompréhensible cette complexité peut
effectivement être liée aux multiples
amendements parlementaires déposés mais
ne peut-on pas considérer que la
nécessité de proposer des amendements
vient du fait que le projet de loi
initial manque de fond qu'il est
insuffisamment ambitieux ou qu'il ne
répond pas aux objectifs fixés la
précipitation avec laquelle nous sommes
forcés de travailler ne permet pas une
réflexion sereine de la sur la loi en
conclusion mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre nous aurions fortes à faire
à contrôler plus l'action
gouvernementale tel est le vœu que je
formule pour les prochains mois je vous
remercie si chers collègues merci
d'avoir été concis monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
nous étions tous ces murs ou le premier
monsieur le sénateur lorsque nous avons
entendu subrepticement évidemment la
Marseillaise retentir à l'instant
j'imagine que cela touchait tous les
sénateurs présents madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur je vous remercie de vos
interventions je crois qu'elles ont été
d'une très grande richesse et d'une très
grande diversité oui le temps nous est
compté je ne pourrais pas me permettre
de faire une réponse exhaustive à chacun
de vous mais vous le savez je suis à
votre disposition pour pouvoir
poursuivre cet échange néanmoins
quelques points collectifs avant de
venir à quelques réponses tout d'abord
saluer le bilan de la commission pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois 14
rapports monsieur le Président on se
débats en sciences publiques depuis sa
création cela montre que c'est une
institution vivante du Sénat vous avez
et c'est vrai souligné un faible taux de
remise des rapports l'explosion des
demandes
900 rapports à mettre pour la 13e
législature c'est un tenable pour le
gouvernement et ces demandes doivent
être mieux ciblées à l'avenir faute de
quoi les rapports les plus éclairants
continueront de passer inaperçu à côté
d'autres moins peut-être ciblés alors je
viendrai maintenant si vous voulez bien
en réponse l'intervention des différents
sénateurs je pense notamment chez Claude
Dilain
ce qui a avec lui je voudrais évoquer
deux particulièrement de loi de la
commission aux affaires économiques
premièrement la loi du de décembre 2011
relative au Certificat d'Obtention
Végétale qui était d'origine proposition
de loi sénatoriale alors c'est vrai le
gouvernement a pris du retard du fait
notamment de l'adoption de la loi du 11
mars 2014 renforçant à la lutte contre
la contrefaçon malgré cela un premier
décrit a été un premier décret a été
pris le 27 juin pour remplacer le comité
de protection végétale par instance
nationale conformément
long terme de la loi trois autres
décrets sont en cours de finalisation
ils seront remis au Conseil d'État
deuxièmement la loi alur c'était les
exemples qui avaient soulevé notamment
monsieur le représentant de la
Commission d'affaires économique la
commission des affaires économiques a
relevé que le texte prévoyait un nombre
très important de mesure d'applications
177 comment voulez-vous que nous
puissions agir d'un seul allant il faut
évidemment prioriser car il est certain
que les administrations ne pourront pas
prendre une centaine de décrets en six
mois c'est très clair que notre travail
parlementaire a été de ce point de vue
insuffisamment priorisé votre collègue
Daniel Renner a mis en avant l'existence
de difficultés dans l'application de la
loi du 28 juillet 2011 tendante à
faciliter l'utilisation des réserves
civiles et militaires en cas de crise
majeure je vous indique qu'un projet de
décret fait actuellement l'objet de
concertation interministérielle il a
déjà été examiné par la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale par
le comité technique de la police
nationale et donc il sera bientôt
proposé au comité technique
ministérielle dès le mois de juillet il
devrait donc pouvoir être publiée dans
la foulée pour la commission des
affaires sociales votre collègue
Catherine Génisson a relevé que les lois
d'origine parlementaire étaient moins
bien traitées du point de vue de leur
application que les lois issues de
projet de loi comme je l'ai déjà dit
devant la commission il n'est pas
acceptable que certaines lois n'est fait
l'objet d'aucune d'aucun texte
d'application alors même qu'elles ont
été adoptées il y a plusieurs mois
j'aimerais donc vous donner des
informations rassurantes sur deux lois
qui relèvent notamment de la compétence
de cette commission pour la loi sur les
soins psychiatriques j'ai été interpellé
là-dessus par Catherine Génisson un
premier décret qui fixe la procédure
applicable devant le juge de liberté de
la détention et au Conseil d'État depuis
le 17 juin le second qui est relatif au
droit des personnes faisant l'objet de
soins psychiatriques et devant la Haute
Autorité de santé qui rendra son avis en
juillet enfin pour la loi de mai 2013
sur la biologie médicale les derniers
décrets sont en cours de finalisation et
la loi sera applic effectivement à
l'automne prend cher Marie-Christine
Blandin pour le compte de la commission
de la culture d'éducation de la
communication a évoqué deux grandes lois
adoptées à l'été 2013 la loi de
refondation de l'école la loi relative à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la roche
je voudrais concentrer ma réponse ici
sur la loi ESR qui cristallise je le
sais beaucoup d'interrogations et sur
lequel je reviendrai 10 mesures doivent
être encore pris pour garantir la mise
en application complète de ces lois
plusieurs d'entre elles entreront en
vigueur avant la rentrée universitaire
2014 nous pouvons nous y engager cette
projet de décret sont actuellement
soumis à la vie de certains organismes
pour des consultations obligatoires et
bien évidemment je vous fournirai la
liste complète de ces textes comme vous
le souhaitez
j'en viens on remarque formuler par
michel Teston au nom de la commission du
développement durable pour lui donner
une information qui sera également
appréciée j'en suis sûr par la
présidente de la commission de la
culture c'est la loi d'avril 2013
relative à l'indépendance de l'expertise
en matière de santé d'environnement à la
protection des lanceurs d'alerte devient
bientôt être intégralement applicable de
projets de décret qui porte sur les
modalités de tenue des registres d'air
d'une part et sur la composition et le
fonctionnement de la commission
nationale de déontologie des alertes en
matière de santé publique et
d'environnement d'autre part seront
publiés très prochainement j'en viens
maintenant à l'intervention du président
Marini évidemment qui a tout
particulièrement insisté sur la loi de
séparation et de régulation des
activités bancaires j'ai noté que sur
différents bancs il y avait approbation
des questions non seulement techniques
mais politiques qu'il pesait qu'il le
faisait et nous pouvons lui dire que il
y a une conscience du gouvernement sur
les points qui l'a posé donc il faudra
bien que le gouvernement de ce point de
vue progresse dans sa réflexion vous
avez eu raison de souligner
l'importance de ce de ce sujet sur
lequel nous avons pris du retard mais il
y a je peux vous rassurer au moins une
quinzaine de décrets qui doivent être
publiés 10 seront publiés avant la fin
de l'année 10 autres et ils sont
aujourd'hui soit devant des instances
consultatives soit devant le Conseil
d'État soit dans le circuit des
contresens mais ce chiffre encourageant
je vous accorde que le gouvernement doit
encore faire des efforts pour aller dans
ce sens donc votre bilan à la fois
d'interpellation est un peu trop sévère
mais il méritait d'être posé madame la
Présidente
Eliane Sassy
vous avez évoqué des principes généraux
de l'activité de nos assemblées des
principes législatifs et donc vous avez
fait un certain nombre de commentaires
comme le fait d'ailleurs une autre de
vos collègues du groupe EUROPE éc ologie
les verts dans un sens un peu différent
je comprends tout à fait vos
interpellations mais
évidemment ceci dépasse le strict nature
de notre débat même s'il est important
de le signaler dans votre démarche je
voudrais quand même dire que
vous abordez comme d'autres collègues la
question des études d'impact peut-être
avec justement le sens de l'impact
lié à la conjoncture qui sait je
voudrais quand même que vous soyez
d'accord avec moi pour reconnaître la
ténacité de la commission qui a pu faire
quand même largement progresser le
travail par le mental et je sais que
vous l'avez noté et je vous en remercie
Madame Nathalie Goulet
est intervenu notamment sur plusieurs
points mais je veux souligner la
question des lanceurs d'alerte sur
lequel j'ai déjà je suis déjà intervenu
précédemment et
également sur l'action de groupe nous
partageons votre préoccupation d'un
sujet essentiel et je sais à quel point
le Sénat a été précurseur en la matière
je suis donc heureux de pouvoir vous
annoncer que les décrets sera publiés
début octobre donc nous avons Monsieur
Philippe caltan bac représentant le
groupe socialiste vous avez souligné que
le renvoi des mesures réglementaires
était parfois pour le législateur un
écran de fumée qui dans l'effet retardé
la mise en application des lois
nous garerions du temps si nous les
mettions effectivement
le renvoi des textes réglementaires et a
fortiori à des degrés en Conseil d'État
sachez que Monsieur la vigne secrétaire
général du gouvernement va tout à fait
dans votre sens et il fait tout ce qu'il
peut lors de l'examen des avant-projet
de loi pour écarter ce type de tentation
donc représentant le groupe écologiste
vous aviez une interrogation tout à fait
radicale sur notre fonctionnement
parlementaire et plus largement les
institutions de la République c'est une
dimension effectivement d'interrogation
à laquelle m'appartient pas de réponse
aujourd'hui
et en même temps
ces questions là évidemment vont poser
aux uns et aux autres peut-être la façon
nouvelle de poser un certain nombre de
questions politiques mais faisons
attention aussi peut-être dans le
contexte où nous sommes de ne pas trop
insisté sur le fait que nous serions
impuissants ce qui est peut-être un peu
exagéré et qui pourrait justifier de la
part de nos concitoyens l'idée que nous
ne savons pas à grand chose ce qui
évidemment
n'est pas forcément très bon et sans
doute un tout petit peu exagéré même si
je comprends vos
préoccupations enfin Monsieur Christophe
André fera ça
nous a évoqué un sujet particulier
qui est la publication tardive du décret
portant réforme de la fe je le déplore
comme vous c'est vrai que ce décret n'a
été publié que le 14 4 mars c'est-à-dire
très peu de jours avant le scrutin mais
je vous rappelle que il avait un
périmètre extrêmement large qu'il
contenait l'ensemble des règles
spécifiques pour l'élection des
conseillers consulaires et comme vous en
doutez ce type de décret demande un
travail technique très minutieux de très
nombreuses concertations et il était
impossible de rédiger ce décret en
quelques semaines voilà mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je n'ai pas
répondu à toutes vos interpellations
néanmoins après ce travail en commission
nous avons pu avoir cet après-midi
un bon débat je le crois et vous le
savez je suis à votre disposition
évidemment tout au long de l'année pour
pouvoir mieux encore répondre à vos
questions en vous remerciant et en
souhaitant bonne chance à notre équipe
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h30 pour le débat sur la Corse et la
réforme territoriale et vous avez donc
là tout le loisir d'aller voir le match
de notre équipe de France la séance est
suspendue